so leute auf gehts
frag mich nicht warum einfach so
So jetzt müsste twitch
Wir sie jetzt entwirren bevor es richtig losgeht jetzt müsste twitch plus von mitkriegen dass der stream online ist das wäre schon mal
extrem exquisite
Exzellent wäre das wenn das der twit ah jetzt hat jetzt haben sie es kapiert
Jogi ucht moin huge
Heute ist pogg ausstrieben weiß ich ob ich es im titel gelesen habt ist massive pogg ausstrieben
Ja
Allerdings hat twitch noch keine notifications versteckt ich sehe das gerade im discord nix angekommen
Oder vielleicht jetzt erst keine ahnung
Heute machen wir mal was was wir sonst nie machen
Es ist nicht wirklich facecam
Facecam machen wir nicht das kann ich ja schon sagen aber es ist gar nicht so weit weg
Ich muss jetzt erst mal warten bis twitch das wirklich kapiert hat dass alle online sind ja oder der titel schreckt alle ab weil die sich denkt
Nee, also wenn der max experimental stream macht dann wollen wir nicht
Teeth cam ja kleiner finger cam
Genau ich werde ich mal ich reakte einfach nur noch einfach einfach reakt ich reakte heute auf ungefähr auf inskorb
21 reactet die auf einen anderen fitness youtuber reactet der auf
Keine ahnung
aerobik 1980 reaktet wir machen dann quadruple reaction inception
Aja ja stream so sieht es ausschrieben dann
Ist vielleicht mal hier rüber schieben so also jetzt als erstes muss ich mich mal ein bisschen über windows aufregend passt mal auf
Ich habe mich gerade eingeloggt in windows und wisst ihr was das erste mal was ich gekriegt habe
You remind me in three days ich weiß ich weiß
Ich weiß nicht wie das wie das heißt in windows dieser screen aber ich versuche euch das mal zu zeigen
Ich habe einen screen gekriegt in windows
Genau das was ist das für ein kacke
Ach ja ich habe jetzt urlaub bis januar habe ich euch das schon mal erzählt
Da könnte ich eigentlich so ist es so nice du da könnte ich den ganzen tag klicken bis januar ja so sieht es aus bis januar
Bis januar so lange hat bestimmt keiner von euch
Läuft ja wie es läuft
Muss so videos für december aufnehmen
Die musik wieder
Sebaru 17 monate poggers 20 2 in serie sebaru dankeschön für 17 monate
Ja und heute gibt es heute gibt es passt mal auf heute heute wird es richtig advanced hier ich habe hier ein äußerst
Experiment also exzellentes experimentelles setup aufgebaut so heute habe ich diesen komischen screen gekriegt nicht das erste mal das erste mal
Das erste mal und habe ich mich gefragt was will windows von mir von mir
Ich habe mich mit meinem windows account eingeloggt mit dem ich mich immer einlogge jeden tag mehrfach
Was wollen die von mir ich ich mache doch ich installiere auch kein office 365 und vor allem warum kann ich nur continue machen und
remind me in three days wer weiß was der macht
Wer weiß was der macht wenn ich continue drückte ich traue den ja ich traue ja microsoft absolut nicht mehr über den weg wenn ich continue
zurück installieren installieren wir wahrscheinlich one drive office 365 und und und ich habe morgen windows phone in der post
Wer weiß wer weiß wer weiß
Was da los ist?
Du brauchst definitiv hetsner sponsoring
Ich habe gesehen es gibt heute
Gucken ob der weg ist heute war ein richtig sau günstiger server glaube 23 euro oder so 6 terabyte
Moment falsch rum
Ne oder
Ne ne das bring ich durcheinander ich habe heute ultra billig so aber was war ne gibts denn vielleicht noch also ich kaufe den nicht aber
Nein nein nein der ist auf jeden fall weg
Es war richtig viel speicher für irgendwie 23 euro oder so es war zwar irgendwie ein oller atlon 64 oder sonst was aber wenn man einfach nur speicher braucht juckt das nicht
Ja 2 mal 3 kann sein aber 2 mal 3 bringt dir bei hetsner nichts weil du hast keinen zugriff aufs bios und kannst das nicht zu kamikaze raid 6 umbauen
Sag mal twitch was ist denn heute los
Schreckt der titel alle ab oder wie
Oder twitch noch nicht die sache was ist denn hier los
Normalerweise ist der zinsen am start aber ich mache schonmal kurz teaser was heute exzellentes passiert nein das da nicht
So pass mal auf exzellent den scheiß machen wir erstmal alles weg alles weg
Ich brauche heute nicht heute nicht heute wieder auch nicht programmiert oder sowas
Ich mach mal kurz ein update weil wir brauchen mplayer
mplayer latency oh wow
Latency freestyler player ist
Aber über kvm ne kannst du nicht
Du siehst doch nur du siehst doch nur das raid 1 was die für dich angelegt haben oder
Du siehst ja nicht 2 mal 3 du siehst ja du siehst ja nur einmal 3 terabyte oder ich hab es noch nicht ausprobiert
So
Disres disrespected 1337 ja pock
Riesch pock dankeschön für die 4 monate
Falsches emote
Ja dankeschön für den sub es ist doch nicht mal prime es ist
Es ist richtig echter subscriber dankeschön ja
Das zeigt was hat mich hier wieder ultra genervt an windows
So ich mach mal kurz update
In der zwischenzeit
Ähm mal kurz was gucken ja es gibt übrigens eine neue tasmotor version
Das ist auch der grund warum ich mich jetzt mal wieder der sache gewidmet habe meine
Mit custom firmware geflashten sachen daheim zu aktivieren äh zu aktualisieren gibt es erst seit 12 tagen
Und gestern übrigens home assistant 118 rausgekommen
Ja so aber das ist alles nicht das was ich euch zeigen will
Ich warte jetzt noch bis mein os geupdatet hat dass ich mplayer installieren kann
Heute machen wir big brain stream leute massive
Too smart exploding brain expanding brain und dann exploding brain machen wir heute
Aber dazu brauche ich mplayer und mplayer kann ich erst machen nachdem ich mein manjaro aktualisiert habe
Ja also es kann sein ups es kann sein dass das nicht wirklich gut funktioniert wie gesagt ist experimentell
Ähm ja
So also ich hab nämlich noch ein paar sachen bestellt auf amazon
Für mich ihr wisst ja ich kann da steckdosen leisten steckdosen und smart home sachen nicht widerstehen
Und die habe ich euch ja das letzte mal schon gezeigt
Und ich habe jetzt davon
Hab ich noch
Davon habe ich noch drei stück drei stück bestellt also das da und das da
Weil ich habe mir letzte Woche schon eine bestellt weil die dinger sind echt nice
Wlan
Du kannst remote schalten du kannst custom firmware flaschen aber nicht so einfach worum es heute geht heute ist expanding brain stream angesagt
Und die können den stromverbrauch messen richtig nice ich habe jetzt eine unten dran habe ich geflasht
Eine unten dran dort wo ich den akku staubsauger immer auflade und ich habe jetzt eine automatisierung gemacht
Dass wenn der stromverbrauch dort wo ich den akku auflade den staubsauger zum akku auflade immer rein stecken wenn der stromverbrauch unter vier watt fällt
Dann schaltet er aus weil dann ist der staubsauger voll
Ja so wenn ich m player installieren kann kann ich euch zeigen um was es heute geht chat ist heute auch so ruhig massive brain ist heute so
m player installieren
Ja ist sogar schon installiert also jetzt passt mal auf m player fps 360
Ich habe deine frage tatsächlich übersehen ja
Wo denn ach hier womit kann ich ah ja moment da machen wir erst mal kurz die questions
Ich bin noch ein bisschen irgendwie am three hats sein ja also
Also womit kann ich am besten die ap requests vom handy von handy apps mit lesen ich brauche die endpoints die nicht dokumentiert sind wir
Ja
Oder in den proxy oder so falls sie falls sie über den proxy sich überreden lassen ja
Weihrauch ist schon halt schlecht du brauchst ja gar kein weihrauch selbst du kannst du machst du gehst du machst linux tcp damp
Und tcp damp schneidest du mit im wireshark format
Ja
Und dann machst du mit tcp damp schreibst schleidest du mit kopierst dir auf ne windows linux desktop kiste und machst damit wireshark aus
Wahrscheinlich spinnen die twitch notifications ja wow ja ja ist ja gut den ganzen scheiß von maus das brauchen wir heute nicht
Alles weg
Ja alles weg person detection
Also pass mal auf heute was wir machen rtsp doppel punkt doppel slash 122 168 1 punkt
146 360 fps
Achtung exzellent ich habe nämlich ein bisschen was aufgebaut
Haha
Bam
Ich habe was aufgebaut wo ein bisschen basteln können
Guck mal hier hand
Exzellent
Hand
Also wir können wir können heute was löten ich habe mein oh fuck mein headset ist das wird ich sage euch das ist ultra experimental stream
Ich guck mal ob ich da hinkomme ohne dass ich meinen headset ob ich das hier runterschmeiß also passt mal auf
Passt mal auf ich habe hier mein löht kolm am start also wir können gleich was löten aber ich will euch was anderes zeigen und zwar
Ich muss jetzt erstmal ähm ich muss jetzt erstmal mein vorschau tablet anmachen
Genau ich werde zum boob cam streamer so siehts aus
Ja wie ich das hier unten weg kriege habe ich noch nicht gecheckt ich glaube das liegt an der app
Mal gucken
Aber
Ich muss erstmal meine vorschau auf dem tablet anmachen sonst sehe ich nämlich den chat nicht richtig
Und die sache ist die ich kann mich zwar umdrehen um den chat zu sehen aber ich habe keinen bock mich permanent umzudrehen
Deswegen kann man das eigentlich verkleinern ah kann sogar verkleinern exzellent
Aber wir machen es gleich vollscreen also ich muss jetzt erstmal hier mein chat aufmachen
Guck hier chat
Ups
Komm jetzt kommt dhl jetzt kommt jetzt kommt dhl werbung
Guck mal kommt dhl null
Das war dhl werbung
Und das warum
Kann das kann kann sich das mal kurz kann sich das mal verpissen
Jetzt sind das hier
Alter ich glaube ich muss mein tablet neu starten das ist gerade übelst am rumspacken
Chat seid ihr das die hacker mans aus dem chat sind das gibt es zu
I'm in ich wusste dass ihr das seid chat
Okay jetzt machen wir mal den poggers experimental stream auf also ihr das auch mal hier seht poggers experimental stream
Und jetzt gehen wir mal hier auf chat jetzt muss ich mal kurz
Warum fängt das jetzt wieder von vorne an
Und jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken
Und jetzt gehen wir mal hier auf chat jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken warum fängt das jetzt wieder von vorne an
Ach hier botch live muss man da machen
Naja
Ah jetzt ist er ah ja
Ja borat ist was das geht auch voll an mir vor wo ist denn der chat ah jetzt ist der chat exzellent chat
Hände liegt ja ja richtig hände liegt so jetzt mache ich das hier neben hin
Und ich muss mein sound ausmachen ich höre mich gerade das ist ziemlich kacke so ich lege das jetzt hier neben hin dass ich hier so ein bisschen vorschau habe
So also chat
Was wir machen können ist ich mache mal kurz fullscreen ich zeige euch mal was erst mal stromanns tablet wie gesagt das wird heute hyper experimental
Massive experimental ich mache mal kurz fullscreen hier
Face liegende reflektion monkaS ja also so ich weiß nicht wie gut das mit dem headset geht
Und ich habe jetzt leider auch keinen direkten vorschau ich sehe es hier nur
Ich habe bestimmt 10 sekunden verzögerungen hier im chat im bild massig massig verzögerungen
Das wird heute monkaSmoke ja also
Ich zeige ich zeige euch mal ein paar sachen zwar wie gesagt ist noch nicht so ganz klar ist noch nicht so ganz klar was was wir genau heute machen
Ich muss ein paar sachen löten ich weiß nicht wie sinnvoll das ist wenn wir das zusammen machen
Zumindest ich werde heute zum ersten mal das da ausprobieren oder zum zweiten mal ich habe es schon mal ausprobiert von der weile aber
Und zwar ich habe mir das auf anraten des chats gekauft
Nur auf anraten des chats also
Mal gucken mal gucken ob das was taugt ja ich bin ich bin ja mal gespannt
Das wird ja empfohlen an allen ecken machen alle werbung dafür ich ich schwör ja sonst eher hier drauf
Das ist ja sonst eher so mein mein bevorzugtes
Ich sehe das wirklich alles mit zehn sekunden verzögerungen da muss man was überlegen
Also das hier ist ja mein persönliches lieblingswerkzeug set wenn man wenn man nur wenn man irgendwie nur mal
Im angebot 35 euro 40 euro wenn man wenn man nur eine sache für den haushalt sich holen könnte an werkzeug
Dann würde ich mir ohne scheiß leute da würde ich mir das holen weil ich bin nicht gesponsert oder so bei vera
Der vera toolcheck ist richtig poggersibbar
Also ich bin ich bin nicht gesponsert
Sag mal was ist der mit meinem tablet mein tablet ist hyper am rumspacken
Was ist das denn warum ist warum spinnt mein tablet so
Der chat ist es ich weiß dass der chat der chat
Der chat hacks auch mein tablet wieder
Swipe ab okay wisst ihr was leute ich starte mal kurz ich starte mal kurz das tablet noch ich weiß nicht was das für schmerzen hat gerade
Ich laufe mal kurz weiter also einmal einmal was hierzu das ist übrigens
So eine gunner optics quickscope brille die hat jetzt da nicht so wirklich viel damit zu tun
Aber was was ich da echt geil dran finde und das habe ich ja schon ein paar mal erzählt zu diesem ding
Also wenn man wenn man sich nur eine sache für den haushalt kauft dann würde ich mir echt das ding kaufen und zwar
Das hat ich muss nebenbei mein tablet neustellen das hat echt alles was man braucht also das hat hier einmal
Ich habe das ist wirklich das sagt mega dass ich kann vorschrauben vorschrauben
Das muss ich das nächste mal schon mal besser machen muss ich mir gleich aufschreiben also da ich mal aufschreiben was wir das nächste mal machen
Ich brauche einen
Vorschau screen ohne delay sonst wird das sonst wird das ziemlich kacke
Nee ich kann es auf tablet machen in vorschau die vorschau sachen
So genau so jetzt ist mein tablet gestartet und geht immer noch nicht
was zum teufel ist mit dem
Was ist mit dem tablet los hat
Ich lasse jetzt mal den strom das liegt am stromkabel
Ich muss jetzt ich muss jetzt erst mal kurz hier chat ich muss euch erst mal wieder aufmachen
Pass auf hier übels
Übels face leak hier wieder gleich watch live soll dass ich den chat überhaupt sehe
Alter was geht da oben ab was zum was was
Ok so die werbung kann jetzt ohne mich laufen
Dedos ist raus ja ja ich merke es chat so also was ich dazu was ich zu dem Dinge sagen wollte also was wirklich poggers ist
Wenn man sich nur eine sache für den haushalt kaufen kann er wird ich mir würde ich mir echt dieses ding gekauft und zwar
Es ist es ist hier auch übelst übelst wackelig das steht hier habe ich hinter meinem schreibtisch gestellt hier dieses setup also das ist
wirklich extrem experimentell und zwar was man was wirklich
Extrem extrem nice an dem ding ist man hat alles dabei was man braucht man kann das hier aufklappen
so
Man hat an bits alles was man braucht man hat von talks
Ja man hat von talks bis zu philips bits bis zu
Kreutztene philips bis zu kreuzschnitz ding an bis zu alles mögliche was man so braucht drin hat sogar adapter falls man noch andere sachen einbauen will
Für diese für diese nüsse hier oben falls man das mal braucht und was richtig nice ist das allein bringt einem ja gar nichts
Man hat hier oben einmal
so eine ratsche dabei
auch richtig nice und
so den mini
so mini schraubendreher dann kann man dann hier zack clips aufmachen
Und sagen wir ok ich brauche jetzt was was ich brauche jetzt talks
Ich brauche jetzt irgendeinen talks machen wir den raus zack schraube schraube schraube es ist klein aber es ist wirklich für alles was dabei also das ist mein mit abstand
Lieblingswerkzeuge set
überhaupt
Das wollte ich jetzt bloß mal los werden aber heute probieren wir das mal mit diesem
Mit dem mit dem i fix it set aus ja so und zwar was ich machen muss ist
Der halter der ratsche verrutscht zu lassen ja es geht ach ja übrigens das geilste habe ich euch ganz vergessen zu zeigen das ist ja noch so ein halter so ein bithalter dabei
So ein bithalter den kann man dann da kann man hier rein machen
Und
Und da kann man sich beispielsweise hier in den bitt nehmen sagen wir jetzt mal keine ahnung ich brauche jetzt hier irgendwie mal sowas da
Das passt mal auf hier macht man jetzt rein jetzt ist der übelst fest wobei habe ich das überhaupt richtig rein gemacht hier unten
Ja ne habe ich schon richtig rein gemacht
Zumindest man kann das auch in den schraubendreher rein machen
Kosten muss man gucken verrat toolcheck plus 40 euro oder so
So und das coole ist das ist hier fest und jetzt passt mal auf
Habt ihr gesehen hier zack kommen wir hier woops hier
Zack und jetzt zack richtig
Powergas
Kann man hier schraube schraube schraube machen oder oder auch ratche ratche ratche je nachdem wie man will also das ist wirklich absolut
Ja um die 50 euro aber ihr müsst mal im angebot gucken die dinger gibt es manchmal im angebot für um die 40 euro
Und mal wie gesagt meiner mann nach lohnt sich das extrem
Meiner mann nach lohnt sich das extrem sich so ein ding zu kaufen wenn man natürlich schon zig
Zeig werkzeugkisten hat oder zig werkzeug setzt oder hast du nicht gesehen ja also wenn man schon alles hat dann braucht man es wahrscheinlich net
Aber wenn man noch nix hat und nur eine sache sich kaufen kann
Dann würde ich auf jeden fall dieses ding hier nehmen
Aber das nehmen wir heute nicht und zwar heute probieren wir das mal probieren wir das ding wo habe ich denn hin
Heute probieren wir mal das da aus das habe ich mir auf anraten des chats damals gekauft hat hat seine vorteile und zwar
Es ist es übrigens keine werbeveranstaltungen habe ich alles selbst gekauft ich krieg dafür nicht mehr was
Und zwar das teil hat der chat gesagt braucht man unbedingt und ich habe es bisher erst einmal gebraucht
Das ergänzt eigentlich den tool check ganz gut weil hier sind ganz viele sachen dabei
Die ich muss mal kurz hier den den esp die man sonst nicht hat ja es ist so ein komisches so ein komisches anti start
Ding dabei was im prinzip die leute eigentlich nur im video anziehen und in echt nie oder chat wie sieht es aus zieht ihr
Zieht ihr einen anti statik armband an wenn ihr was an technik macht also ich nicht
Ist die kameraposition verrutscht
Nein klar lul weh
So ja ich muss gucken dass ich das richtig positioniert habe so und dann ist hier noch so klein scheiß dabei also irgendwie für den hobby zahnarzt
irgendwelche
Dinger ja
Aber
Ja
So
Ja aber ja
Das ist jetzt nicht so toll aber was echt praktisch ist da dran also jetzt ernsthaft das da kam ob man diesen krempel hier braucht
Da kann man sich jetzt streiten ja das ist jetzt frag fraglich das hier ist noch ganz cool wenn man mal sachen aufhebeln muss ja
Aber ansonsten es geht so aber was richtig nice ist und warum das finde ich sogar eine ganz gute ergänzung zum tool check ist
Ist wenn man hier mal reinguckt hier sind ganz viele dinge drin die man eben sonst nicht hat
Also sprich man hat hier beispielsweise so ein ding ich weiß legit gar nicht was das ist was ist das chat was ist es was was ist das
Einer von euch irgendwie einen plan was das hier ist
Man sieht nicht das ganze bild doch
Also ich sehe es ja gerade in der forschung man sieht die komplette matte mehr soll man auch nicht sehen wie gesagt viel mehr ist hier
Hier ist auch mehr oder weniger gleich schluss hier vorne ich habe das ich habe da jetzt so ein komisches
Türmchen aufgebaut hinter hinter meinem schreibtisch ja und da hat man solche komische
Dinger dabei ja keine ahnung was ist was es ist oder oder wie gesagt hier für den
Für den der gerne zahnarzt spielt oder so weiß ich zumindest ist das ganz nützlich das ding ganz ehrlich so geil ist es
Jetzt nicht hat er den vorteil man kann
Warte mal machen wir irgendwas rein
Man kann halt hier
Den da machen also quasi drehen drehen und dings hier oben also das ist ganz praktisch aber das kannst du bei den
meisten anderen dieser dieser wie heißt das diese diese klein diese ja
Fein motorig schraubendreher dinge auch
Ja aber das ist als ergänzung ganz gut und was ich mich gerade frage haben wir hier vielleicht ein adapter dass ich das in
Mein tool check machen kann das ey das passt oder guck mal das müssen adapter sein dass das sind das tool check passt
Sekunde wo habe ich tool check ha
Wo habe ich das tool check
Ok ich habe das tool check irgendwo hingeschmissen wo sie ist
Ach hier hinter mir legt es ja das habe ich jetzt nicht gefunden
Was übrigens doof ist ich sehe hier in der guck mal hier ich sehe hier in meiner vorschau zwar was ihr schreibt aber ich sehe nicht ob ihr
Ed Wubblos schreibt oder so
Also das heißt es könnte sogar sein dass ich was über sehe
Aber ich gucke dann aber ich gucke dann nachher durch jetzt bin ich jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das geht guck mal das da das da
Und jetzt nehmen wir mal hier die ratchet vom tool check
Aber ich guck dann aber ich guck dann nachher durch jetzt bin ich jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob das geht guckt mal das da das da und jetzt nehmen wir mal hier die Ratsche vom Toolcheck
mit dem Bithalter vom Toolcheck und gucken mal
ah ok den Bithalter braucht man gar nicht wirklich der Bithalter ist eigentlich overrated
ah guck mal das geht ja sogar das heißt ich kann jetzt hier irgend so ein Crap nehmen was
braucht man hier zum Beispiel das braucht man für wo ist das für iPhones wo ist das für iPhones
das da glaube ich das habe ich gebraucht letztens das habe ich weiß nicht mehr für was das habe
ich letztens gebraucht so ein Dreieckschrauben Ding und das ist ja richtig cool guck mal wenn
das da vorne jetzt rein passt oder auch nicht ganz schön ganz schön eng passt das nicht
guck mal das passt what the fuck was ist denn das warum passt das nicht guck mal hier ah doch man
muss einfach nur drücken es fuck ja so ja aber das ist ja richtig nice ich sehe ja zum ersten
mal dass ein Adapter für das Toolcheck dabei ist das ist ja Massive Poggers guck mal das ist ja
nice wusste ich gar nicht sehe ich zum ersten mal gerade gut man lernt nie aus wo habe ich
denn das jetzt her hier so und jetzt zeige ich euch mal was heute ansteht Verwirrung so viel
Zeug was heute ansteht zeige ich euch mal mache ich packe jetzt aber erstmal mein Toolcheck wieder
ein Toolcheck Clips Clips falsch rum oder Clips Clips alles gut ich mache das Toolcheck mal weg
so und zwar man muss einfach nur drücken es fuck ja so ist es bei vielen Sachen so muss man nur
drücken gachibas drücken muss man da kann ich jetzt eigentlich wenn ich mich hier umdrehe noch
Emotes auf der Lane ah excellent habe ich irgendwas übersehen kommt mal kurz chat habe
irgendwas übersehen viele dieser besonderen bilds in verschiedene spezialtraum wie nintendo ja ja
deswegen habe ich mir auch gekauft die twitch werbung die liefern sich gerade einen duel ihr
müsst einfach eure quickscope brille aufziehen dann habt ihr auch keine twitch werbung mehr die
liefern sich gerade ein duel mit youblog mal gehts mal gehts nicht
das hier baro schreibt ja schon die ersten bits verloren ja das geht schnell ok so jetzt
zeige ich euch mal was ich gekauft habe wo ich mir aber nicht sicher bin ob wir das heute im
stream schon machen wir gucken es uns nur mal an und zwar kann man die nachkaufen also die
vera dinger kannst du nachkaufen da kannst du jedes einzelne ding nachkaufen so also erstens muss
ich das können wir vielleicht zum einstieg machen ich muss ein vemos mini mit pins versorgen weil
mein stromzähler im keller den geist aufgegeben hat und das ist ein esp 866 d1 mini das heißt ich
kann ihr einfach austauschen weiß ich was der für schmerzen hat vielleicht liegt auch an
irgendwas anderem aber der ist kran also den müssten wir mit pins versorgen ich habe hier
mal eine box mitgebracht mit jede menge pins habe ich so sammeln surium an pins drinne so
ich glaube den hier den hier braucht man wobei das ist viel zu lang guck mal und es passt
doch nicht da fehlt ein pin seht ihr das guck mal da fehlt ein pin anzeige ist raus warum liefern
die das mit dem pin zu wenig gehen wir eher davon aus wir brauchen alle was braucht ihr so so was
hier den da brauchen wir exzellent dankeschön für den sub wer war es denn hier vollkorn misch
pro neun monate exquisite subscription dankeschön falls ich irgendwas über seh heute seht es mir
nach sind das ja das ist kratzer von der katz ich bin nicht irgendwie selbstwert gefährdet oder so
ich habe freund mit der katz gespielt und die spielt hier am liebsten mit meiner hand und dann
kam da sowas raus ja die schlimmer aus als es ist ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher an welcher
stelle ich die pins dran hatte ich vermute mal da müsste ich jetzt eigentlich im keller gucken ich
vermute mal so rum weil ich das 3d gedruckte gehäuse so rum hab also wahrscheinlich muss ich die pins
so rum ran machen muss man mal schauen dankeschön für den sub wer haben wir hier krelax zwölf
monate zwölf monate zwölf monate ist pogga zwölf monate ist ja schon quasi sekunde nein falsch
zwölf monate ist hypersubscriber kurzer keller stellts ne ich geh jetzt nicht in keller also das
müssen wir machen aber was ich eigentlich im stream vor hab ich muss übrigens unbedingt die box
zu machen weil ich habe schon mal den fehler gemacht die box nicht zuzumachen uns dann runter
zu schmeißen und das ist schlecht ich bin ja mal einmal in so ein ding reingetreten also quasi
in so eins hier hatte ich mal in der verse stecken das war das war nicht so exzellent
monac s ja das tut also wie gesagt nur so ein hier so ein pin von so einem kabel hier guckt mal
so ein kabel pin hatte ich mal in der verse stecken ja das hat ein bisschen weh getan aber man
konnte verkraften so also und zwar was ich mir gekauft habe bei amazon bei amazon wie das die
coolen leute sagen wir sind ja hier unter unter uns ja ihr wisst ja ich kann bei steckdosen leisten
nicht wieder stehen und ich habe einmal die gekauft die ich euch da vorhin gezeigt habe die da das
problem bei denen ist die lassen sich nicht alle mehr über das wlan flaschen und deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht wir können mal in so einem stream hier deswegen ist es ja so ein bisschen
experimentier stream für freude mal gucken ob wir die auf kriegen und schauen ob wir an die pins
dran kommen und dann ich habe hier neben raspberry pie liegen ich weiß ich auch mit das blinken sie
müssen ein bisschen blinken da und dann können wir gucken ob wir die über die pins geflasht
bekommen ich habe theoretisch alles da die frage ist nur ob man das aufbekommt also ich habe meinen ich
habe meinen esp programmer da das ist dieses teil das kommt ein paar usb an raspberry und hier
kommen hier das hier sind die pins die man anlöten muss können wir probieren ob das geht
und dann habe ich noch was dann habe ich noch was und zwar ja also keine ASMR sounds sondern
ich muss erstmal aufmachen das habe ich schon vor einer weile gekauft und das ist ganz abartig zu
löten und zwar das hier ist ein ich weiß nicht ob man es da sieht irgendwas steht da drauf xy bf usb
hast du nicht gesehen das ist ein schalter für usb geräte also sprich da macht man hier ganz
normal usb rein es hat glaube ich in usb 2.0 daten datenleitung warum das grün ist weiß ich
nicht irgendwelche chinesen haben sich gedacht grün ist die beste farbe für usb keine ahnung
so zumindest ist es ein schalter für usb also sprich so wie man hier normale geräte schalten
kann 230 volt an der steckdose geräte kann man hier usb geräte ein und ausschalten das ist ganz
nützlich weil man hat mittlerweile relativ viele usb geräte die man einzeln also ich zumindest weiß
ich wie es bei euch aussieht chat wahrscheinlich bin ich auf der welt der einzige der sowas hat aber
zum beispiel den raspberry pi im keller raspberry pi 0 im keller wenn der den geist aufgibt muss
ich in keller gehen so würde ich den in den raspberry pi jetzt hier dran stöpseln dann
könnte ich den hart resetten über normalerweise muss kann man diesen knopf hier drücken und dann
macht er diesen macht der usb an und aus aber das ganze kann man auch über wlan machen das
ist ein usb relay genau so und es ist quasi ein relay mit mit usb anschließen das ist ganz
nützlich das problem ist natürlich wie bei allem es geht nur mit china zeug so und das kann man auch
flaschen da kann man das motor drauf flaschen und dazu muss man das ding aber erstmal irgendwie
aufmachen aufmachen anlöten und gucken so und als nächstes haben wir noch was nächstes haben
wir noch was da muss jetzt einmal kurz ein bisschen ein bisschen platz machen weil das ist ein bisschen
größer zwar habe ich mir noch eine andere sache gekauft aber die probiere ich erstmal mit dem also
die nächste sache probiere ich erstmal mit dem raspberry pi zu flaschen und zwar ich habe
eine große steckdose leistung kauf ich nämlich so eine aber auf vor also im prinzip irgendein
china hersteller der nicht nach china hersteller aussehen will keine ahnung hier specialized
in manufacturing smart power strip alles klar das ist mit sicherlich mit sicherheit das einzige
was die machen das ist eine gamer prille das ist eine moment wo steht die kirby musiker das
ist eine gunner optik ich hoffe man erkennt das hier irgendwie eine gunner optik scope prille
ist das glaubt man erkennt nicht oder hier müsste ich mal scharf stellen jetzt gunner
optik scope ja ein bisschen vergrößerung ist eigentlich ganz nice deswegen verwende ich die
zum löten weil die ein bisschen vergrößerung hat und ich finde das gelbe passt da auch ganz
gut dazu zumindest dieses teil habe ich mir bestellt hier wir packen das mal aus und guckt
mal kurz wie das ausschaut ob sich das überhaupt lohnt oder ob ich das lieber wieder zurückschickt
weil das ist schon ganz schöner das ist schon ein ganz schöner klotz hier guckt euch das mal an
mal kurz hier den kram weg machen das ist schon ganz schöner klotz was halt was halt an der ganz
cool ist wie gesagt weil immer die frage kommt warum ich das flasche das liegt einfach daran
normalerweise kann man das nur verwenden mit der offiziellen handy app und auch nur über die
china cloud das sind ja zwei sachen die ich nicht haben will also ich will erstens meine sachen hier
heimautomatisierung technisch nicht nur über eine handy app bedienen können und schon mal gar nicht
nur über eine cloud in china das ist der hauptsächliche grund warum ich den kram flasche
so packen wir das mal kurz aus und gucken also die ist ganz schön die ist ganz schön fett ganz schön
fett und unförmig dieses ding ich meine der vorteil ist man hat einen knopf für jede für jede
jedes loch man kann wahrscheinlich einmal komplett an und ausschalten man hat viermal usb ist
eigentlich ganz nice so und das probiere ich jetzt das probieren aber zu flaschen übers wlan weil
die will ich nicht aufschrauben also wir können jetzt zwei sachen machen wir können jetzt probieren
das ding mal über die pie zu flaschen übers wlan ob das funktioniert oder wir machen die hier mal
auf oder wir versuchen die mal aufzumachen und gucken ob wir dann die pins dran kommen was was
wollen mit mit was wollen wir anfangen chat ihr könnt euch aussuchen wobei gemerkt geflasht
über die pie übers wlan haben wir ja schon das ist jetzt ja nix so wahnsinnig neues auf flexen
ja gut aufmachen lull ja sehe ich auch so aufmachen ist das beste macht die kleine auf
ja gut dann probieren das mal schauen wir mal ob man da dran kommt also leute es wäre
massive poggers wenn wir es wirklich schaffen würden das ding aufzumachen anzulöten und zu
flaschen im stream das wäre explode expanding exploding brain wäre das und diesmal ihr wisst
ja manchmal tue ich so manchmal tue ich so manchmal schiebe ich euch ja manchmal tue ich so dass ich
sachen mache als würde ich die als würde ich die sachen neu machen obwohl ich obwohl ich
vorher schon mal gemacht habe aber diesmal habe ich das wirklich noch nicht gemacht ich
habe da zwar schon die steckdosen geflasht ja zum beispiel hier die haben wir zusammen angeguckt
hier die da also die die habe ich auch aufgemacht dran gelötet geflasht das ging man sieht ja noch
ein bisschen den den heißkleber übrigens sie sieht man das loch wo ich es aufgemacht erkennt
man das da wusste ich rein da wusste ich mit dem schrauben rein hämmern dass das funktioniert
dafür guckt man die sich nur von oben alles alles gut guck mal hier wunderbar außer dass
hier ein bisschen außer dass hier ein bisschen heißkleber ist ist alles gut ja also wie gesagt
das habe ich schon das ist die erste mal dass ich das mache aber die hier noch nicht probiert
absolut kein plan also mal gucken ob wir das hinkriegen schauen wir mal gucken wir uns das
ding erst mal an also erst mal erst mal aufmachen erst mal aufmachen das teil als nächstes
brauche ich hier noch irgendwie ein mikro dass man hört was ich mache zumindest ein
bisschen im hintergrund also was haben wir hier also das ist eindeutig ich mache mal
das teil wieder weg hier also das ist eindeutig das teil was ich schon habe auch kein unterschied
man kann hier hier so ein fall drauf man kann hier die obere steckdose anschalten man kann
hier die untere steckdose anschalten den kram machen wir auch mal ab ist hier was cooles
ihr seht das wackeln vom tisch gar nicht so sehr das liegt da dran weil die kamera mit
wackelt mit dem tisch exzellent weil das ist ziemlich wackelige konstruktion die ich hier
aufgebaut habe mein maus habe ich den maus zeige ja drin ja gleich weg das motor läuft
auch überall drauf oder ja so lang sind esp 32 sp 86 ist ist die chance gut bei allem anderem
hast du gelitten deswegen musste ich ja die letzte steckdosen leiste zurückschicken weil
also nicht die hier sondern die die andere nicht bestellt hat da war auf einmal ein mediatek
als controller drin und kein esp 266 so also wo kriegt man das ding hier auf wie gesagt
das ist wirklich blind ich habe keinen plan ja hier wo könnte man das aufkriegen hier
aufhebeln guckt mal hier hinten vielleicht aufhebeln was heißt flaschen custom also
neue firmwirt drauf machen ich hole gleich mal ein dremel und dremel auf vielleicht hier
hinter irgendwo gut da kommt jetzt der platte da kommt jetzt der punkt wir gucken einfach
mal im internet was andere leute da schon gemacht den presslufthammer chat ich will das ding
euch kaputt machen wir gucken jetzt einfach mal im internet ob das andere schon gemacht
haben gosund sp 211 tasmotor so nochmal gosund ja ich habe letztens einen guide gefunden
wie das geht aber das war für die sp 112 so sp 112 ging das so man musste hier in das
loch aber dieses loch das gibt es da gar nicht das gibt es da gar nicht das loch also
das funktioniert schon mal nicht wie kriegt man das auf hier guckt mal guckt mal das ist
was anderes blitzwolf das ist das ist alles der gleiche krab da gibt es da gibt es doch
irgendjemand der da open der da ein paar screenshots von gemacht hat das ist was sp 1 das ist was
anderes ein loch rein machen hier das sieht doch gut aus wie hat er das aufgekriegt guck
mal den habe ich mir auch gekauft diesen usb lötkolben einfach aus spaß an der freundin
der hat der ist der sagt wirklich guck mal da sind schrauben da sind schon schrauben
drin wo sind die denn kurz so von der rückseite her gibt es eine kreuzschlitzschraube aber
das ist eine andere guck da ist nix da gibt es keine kreuzschlitzschraube zeigt nochmal
die einsteckseite ok warte also ich vermute mal wir müssen das hier hinten aufhebeln hier
oder man muss das raus machen aber das kann man nicht raus machen hier das kann man nicht
raus machen das ist fest die kann man nicht raus machen die sind da oder ok probieren
wir das mal aus jetzt kommt jetzt kommt beck beck sieht flaschen kommt jetzt ich sag's
euch leute wird gebeck sieht flascht vom chat jetzt wissen alle wieder besser als ich ich
sehe schon kommen so also gucken wir mal probieren wir das probieren wir das doch mal aus ob wir
das aufkriegen wir probieren vorher noch mal was anderes und zwar probieren wir mal folgende
sache wir nehmen uns mal dieses komische dieses komische zahnarzt set hier das da das da und
was ist das hier das da und das da ich war übrigens beim zahnarzt vorgestern richtig
gesagt so gucken wir mal ob wir da theoretisch vielleicht irgendwie was rauskriegen hiermit
nope keine chance die kriegste nicht raus leute die kriegste nicht raus das bauerschraub macht
da auch werbung für keine chance die kriegste nicht raus das kriegste nicht raus gemacht
sind da sind da vielleicht schrauben drin sind da vielleicht schrauben drin hier schrauben
drin moment da muss ich mal kurz den hier holen was hast du mit die katze hat mich gekratzt
die gehen nicht raus nein nein die gehen nicht raus guck mal hier ich ziehe da grad übelst
dran ganz vergessen schicko wars ja aber was sein kann ist ich brauche da mal irgendwas
zum rein zum rein bohren also nicht bohren wirklich bohren sondern rein stechen und gucken
ob da vielleicht schrauben dahinter sind ob hier vielleicht schrauben dahinter sind sind
hier schrauben dahinter leute ne oder sind keine schrauben dahinter da schrauben ich
seh nix ne da sind keine schrauben vergessts oh da hat einer du hast ein bild gefunden
wie man es aufkriegt excellent schraubchamp ja ah guck mal hier der chat der chat ist
wieder richtig massive brain ich sag doch heute ist big brain time aha so ein explodierbild
what the fuck da sind schrauben ok es sind schon mal keine schrauben von vorne zugänglich
oder die schrauben sind hinten genau da sind keine schrauben wo sind nicht schrauben von
unten von unten wir müssen unten aufmachen die technik ist hier nicht zu sehen drauf
da kann man innen drin sind irgendwo kontakte müssen wir mal gucken ganz links sieht man
schraubenlöcher wo hier ja da bin ich jetzt echt überfragt wie man das wie man das gehäuse
aufhebeln ja das ist eine andere das ist eine andere das ist eine andere aber das das probiere
ich jetzt das probiere ich jetzt das probieren wir jetzt leute das das probieren wir jetzt
aus ob wir das aufkriegen oder dass ich mach den mal kurz hier ein bisschen den kram weg
ob wir das hier aufkriegen ach du kacke ach du scheiße im leben nicht i'm in chat
ok kann man da jetzt irgendwie mit mit mit haken dran hat man da jetzt irgendwie mit
das kriegt man doch im leben so nicht auf da kannst du nicht drumherum fahren richtig
ok so ist das schon mal nicht gedacht ich darf auch nicht zu sehr da drin rum
vorwerken weil es geht kaputt postchamp die kriegt man nicht raus die rgb teile die das
ist das ist aufgeklebt hier guckt mal das ist quasi aufgedruckt auf plastik also hier
kannst du vergessen ihr kriegste nichts raus und da sind auch keine schrauben seht ihr
da sind da sind keine schrauben dahinter
es bleibt uns eigentlich nichts anderes übrig wie den kram hier aufzuhebeln denke ich mal
glaube das ist das ist aber echt kacke das ding mache ich komplett kaputt ok ich muss
noch mal auf das bild gucken ich muss noch mal auf das bild gucken ja gut das problem
ist das bild bringt mir nichts das hier ich erkenne auf dem bild nix
die dinger hier wahrscheinlich leute wisst ihr was wisst ihr was das sein wird das ist
wie bei allem das ist wie bei allem man muss das einfach nur mit ordentlich kraft machen
ganz links das weiße teil welches das hier das da
so viel clips an den langen seiten das ist hier nicht
ganz links wo ist links das hier die hier meint ihr na das da ok das kann man mal ausprobieren
ok das probieren wir mal aus postchamp hier
das das geht kaputt da kommt man nicht ran kommt mal hier das die gibt schon den geist
auf ich meine ich könnte mal draufhauen ob es aufgeht das sagt ja mal sowas von du hast
auch heißkleber gucken was auf der seite abgeht das ist übrigens kein messer by the
way da kann man sich da kann man sich nicht schneiden hier ansonsten trug ich mir einfach
ein neues gehäuse genau also rein kommt man easy wisst ihr was wahrscheinlich muss man
einfach nur wie kriegt man das auf
guckt mal hier postchamp postchamp fast fast
das ist brutal fest alter der clip ist schon raus die anderen clips sind aber noch drin
guck mal der clip ist schon raus was meinst du valentin zeig mal
valentin was meinst du im discord sebaro oder falls ich ein motto ist können wir das bild
mal im chat posten was er was am discord gepostet hat so nice danke sebaro exzellent das kenne
ich schon das das habe ich doch schon naja also hier das das sind die das sind die laschen
die moment guck mal das hier sind gar keine die laschen sind nur auf einer seite kann
das sein probieren wir noch mal von der anderen seite aus wieso machst du das ding auf flaschen
custom firmware drauf ach hier rot ja die habe ich doch schon gesehen
die habe ich doch schon gesehen die habe ich doch schon gesehen ja und ich habe also ich
zeig es euch noch mal die gehen auch auf aber das problem ist dass die auf der anderen seite
drin stecken also guckt wartet mal und mensch muss erst mal wieder rein so weiß ich auch
mal das gescheit erkennt also das geht die sind sogar draußen aber die anderen sind
ja noch drin ich wüsste was ich werde jetzt einfach mal
okay das ist nicht so robust wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe okay weiter geht's durch
sowas durch sowas lassen wir uns natürlich nicht entmutigen das bin wir einfach wieder
einfach wieder zurück und gut ist probieren von der anderen seite noch mal also ich habe
jetzt ja von allen seiten das schon mal ein bisschen gelockert vielleicht vielleicht
komme ich da jetzt rein alter das ist wirklich scheiße aufzukriegen wisst ihr das also es
gibt kann es vielleicht sind hier und vielleicht sind unter den knöpfen die knöpfe kriegt
man raus dass man die aufmachen kann aber da ist keine schraube dahinter ist ein knopf
dahinter ich mein einfacher wäre es wenn man den scheiß hier raus machen kann aber das
geht nicht das könnt ihr vergessen das geht nicht ab war auf beiden seinen spalt ja dazu
bräuchte ich irgendwas für beide seiten wo ist mein tool check ich guck mal wir noch
was drin haben was man auch gebrauchen kann man hier noch irgendwas haben ne pinzette das
ding ist sofort im arsch ich hol jetzt mal mein tool check und ram da mal was rein gachibas
schlitzbett genau so sieht es aus aber zu dick zumindest eins ist klar das bricht schon
mal nicht ab
es war fast auf es war es war fast auf vielleicht kommt aber vielleicht kommt mir hier noch
an der seite rein das probiere ich noch mal an der seite keine chance also wir müssen
sie hier irgendwie
ja man normalerweise wenn es knack macht gehts auf aber das geht nicht auf warum haben
die da auch keine keine schraube oder sowas drin wenn da ist keine schraube leute wenn
ich ist legit keine da mal von oben reingucken ne da ist keine schraube das ist die anschlüsse
das sind die anschlüsse für den strom da ist keine schraube dahinter das wäre so einfach
wenn da eine schraube dahinter wäre das macht mich fertig das ding kann man das hier irgendwie
also das eins muss man ihn lassen die haben das ziemlich exquisite zugemacht excellent
wir müssen das wir müssen gewinnen wir müssen siegen heute hier über die steckdose das
ist hier auch auf also ich kann da drunter gucken da ist da ist nichts mehr was das hält
auf der seite muss da mit dem bit rein ich glaube ich muss mir mal ein paar größere
ich muss mir gerade noch mal das andere schraubendreher set holen weil hier tut sich nix das ist auch
nicht lang genug gleich wie soll ich alter beide seiten gleichzeitig jetzt wird jetzt
excellent der chat ist big brain beide seiten gleichzeitig achtung achtung beide seiten
gleichzeitig was ne kacke alter was das hier ich komme echt vor wie der zahnarzt
ok leute ich gehe jetzt mal ich gehe mal kurz andere schraubenzieher holen weil ich
glaube die hier sind zu klein oder die sind zu klein ja die sind auch nicht die hochwertigsten
also das hier das geht never kaputt aber dem kram bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht
so sicher zumal er auch zu fett oben ist guckt euch mal hier das ist schon mega im arsch
kacke w kacke triple ur ah moment ich hab ne idee ich hab ich hab ne idee achtung big
brain big brain idee wir machen hier auf wir drücken das hier auf ja ich sehe ich sehe
die laschen also die halten das nicht so großartig und jetzt jetzt machen wir hier an der seite
irgendwie auf was hätte zum drunter hier so hier so postchamp ha es war fast auf ok
ich gehe mal kurz ich gehe mal das große schraubenzieher holen das sind vier stück
und gleich wieder da
excellent es werden stärkere geschütze aufgefahren so also postchamp
das da hier den können wir gebrauchen excellent übrigens auch super dinger hier zack gut
damit probieren wir das jetzt mal damit haben wir jetzt auch ordentlich wums so die sind
jetzt ein bisschen dicker aber damit habe ich ordentlich kraft würde ich mal sagen
machen wir hier mal auf das ist poggers clocks hd ich glaube ich habe gerade den knopf geschrottet
ich habe gerade glaube ich den knopf geschrottet der macht nichts mehr naja kriegen wir bestimmt
wieder gefixt gleich moment habe ich das eben auf der anderen ich habe es eben auf der anderen
seite gemacht ich habe es eben auf der seite gemacht wo wir so gut reingekommen sind ja
genau hier jetzt runter gedrückt wartet mal so wie habe ich das eben gemacht das ding
ist schon mega im arsch bald bald ist es echt das ist wie das große vera set heißt
das ist irgendein wäre elektriker set ich krieg anfälle hier das muss jetzt reicht
jetzt reicht jetzt reicht jetzt gibt es jetzt jetzt kriegt er kriegt er aufs maul
und nämlich verarschen what the fuck
monkeis was ist das was zum teufel ist das
ja beim zack kommt mal wie kaputt das ding jetzt schon ist er ok jetzt darf ich darf
das nicht raus machen er ok ok moment mein finger ok ok jetzt lass mal gucken das ist
echt nicht ohne das ist echt nicht ohne also es ist wie immer einfach ordentlich kraft
und hier muss ich aufpassen ich darf hier nicht ich muss ja unbedingt was drunter halten
weil ich muss ja unbedingt was drunter halten weil ansonsten mache ich das gehäuse kaputt
und das sieht halt kacke aus war eine schwere geburt moment das ding ist noch nicht auf
das ding ist ja noch nicht auf das ganze müsste jetzt wahrscheinlich auf der anderen seite
auch noch mal machen ist eine schraube seht ihr das leute da ist eine schraube wo kommt
die her seht ihr das eine schraube wo schraubts wo kommt es her wo kommt die schraube her
die kommt von unten irgendwo das gucken wir uns gleich an wir machen jetzt erstmal auf
das ding irgendwie ich ziehe da jetzt einfach mal dran was habe ich jetzt gemacht das nicht
gut wenn da dinger nach außen stehen die nicht nach außen stehen sollten glaube ich
so ich habe schiss dass ich es wieder aus versehen zumach ich stecke jetzt mal irgendwas rein
dass es auf jeden fall auf bleibt so exzellent so als würde den scheiß auf der anderen
seite auch noch machen so achtung post jam post jam ich muss den daumen drunter machen
sonst mache ich das gehäuse kaputt so moment ich habe eine tastatur halb runter geschmissen
das war okay und es ist nix abgebrochen guck mal es ist nix abgebrochen das ist ein bisschen
schepp das ist ein bisschen schepp aber an sich ist okay oh leute leute der knopf geht
wieder ich habe den knopf aus irgendwelchen kunden wieder ganz gemacht ich weiß nicht
genau warum aber der knopf knopf wieder okay danke für den sup ich weiß nicht genau
wer war wer war es hier der karlson 14 monate dankeschön karlson exzellent dankeschön für
den sup okay gekonnt geöffnet muss weil ja es ist übung macht den meister du okay was
haben die chinesen hier drin gemacht seht ihr da ist ne schraube seht ihr das leute da
ist ne schraube da ist ne schraube die war die schraube war da drin seht ihr das das
kann man das kann man aufschrauben von oben das kann man aufschrauben von oben die frage
ist nur von wo gut als erstes werden wir jetzt mal haben wir da irgendwie einen passenden
einsatz für erstes schrauben wir das mal ab was ist das hier eine kleine kreuz schlitz
schlitz kreuz ding so was da das sind glaube die aufkleber die aufkleber auf den dosen
gehen nicht raus kannst du voll knicken das habe ich ausprobiert hier guck die gehen
nicht raus außer die brechen vielleicht ab wenn haben wir hier dankeschön für den sup
desortion vier monate dankeschön poggers das haben meine hand war die katz also ich
hab nicht irgendwie mich mit leuten am hauptbahnhof gekloppt oder so chat merkt euch mal der
schwarze ist da traten das muss ich mir irgendwie merken ich muss merken wo was ist das ding
sieht immer gleich aus ich glaube so rum was drin so rum so rum was drin das sind aufkleber
überrubbel die ab das aufkleber sind keine aufkleber das ist da drauf wobei doch post
camp post camp post camp post camp ich glaube wir hätten uns das sparen können post camp
was ist das hier wie geht das ab ich muss das abmachen ok also wir zerstören die dinger
jetzt komplett so wie es gerade aussieht also ich will ich will die aufkleber eigentlich
abmachen weil das sieht das sieht dann scheiße kaputt aus hier in der mitte ist eine schraube
leute hier in der mitte ist eine schraube ne hier in der iske leute da ist nichts drunter
da ist nichts da steht nur eine zwei drauf da ist keine schraube da ist keine schraube
da ist nur eine zwei drauf da ist nichts da ist keine schraube das bringt nichts wenn
ich das abmache egal also so so rum so rum war das also so rum war das drin das muss
ich mir merken das muss wir suchen wieder rein ich brauche einen stift ich gucke einfach
im stream dann nach wie es war also hier guckt da schrift so so war es da schrift dahinter
seite und hier so gut wenn man den stream mit laufen hat so dann machen wir das jetzt
mal ab guck mal hier wie es kaputt gegangen ist hier oben ist bei wechselspannung egal
ich glaube schon aber ich bin kein electro pro deswegen mache ich ja auch nicht an irgendwelchen
live sachen rum
das mal abmachen und dann gucken wir mal weiter kann das mal kann das mal rausgehen das wobei
eigentlich warum soll ich das raus machen solange sich raus fällt ist doch eigentlich
alles ok doch es fällt raus guck mal dafür sind diese fächer hier oben wirklich poggers
ich habe am anfang gedacht so ein kack braucht man nicht aber ich hatte das mal das ist echt
ganz praktisch diese komischen felder da oben so ok wie kriegen wir das teil jetzt weiter
auf wie kriegen wir das jetzt weiter auf da sind schrauben hier sind schrauben schrauben
hier schrauben schrauben schrauben excellent exquisite schrauben da sind schrauben excellent
so da schraubst du mal aha ha ha ha da ist der controller ach du scheiße das sind überhaupt
keine pins da kommt man überhaupt nicht dran ach guck mal hier unten sind pins rx tx poggers
ha pins pins excellent excellent pins excellent also ok welche pins sind was jetzt wird es
kompliziert mein multimeter habe ich keine ahnung wo das ist sonst also kenne ich mich
damit mit so elektro kram nicht wirklich gut also wir brauchen auf jeden fall gpio 0 ich
glaube mal dass das hier gpio 0 ist es das gpio 0 was steht da drauf erkennt ihr das
leute was was was steht da drauf 0 ich erkenne es nicht dort vor gauze und drunter steht
jetzt sind die schrauben nee jetzt guck mal guck mal ha ha ha ha leute leute force champ
force champ wo ist der haken
da ist die schraube lol kz fbs schraube ja auf der anderen seite ok gut gut gut gut
gut gut gut gut gut gut zu wissen gut zu wissen das bedeutet ich muss irgendwie das
machen wir jetzt mal für die für das nächste das heißt ich muss irgendwie hier guck mal
hier muss ich irgendwie ah guck mal hier kann man das abmachen ach du scheiße ok da muss
man aber übelst aufpassen dass man das hier
da muss man ein bisschen feinfühlig sein dass man das wieder so abkriegt dass man es
nicht wieder dran bekommt das ist ja voll für den arsch auf der anderen seite ich meine
selbst wenn das kaputt ist selbst wenn das kaputt ist dann ist es ja auch nicht schlimm
ne mein finger ich komm da nicht ran fein mechaniker wirst du nicht mal nee kein fall
komm mal hier force champ jetzt haben wir es jetzt haben wir es aber abkriegen ohne dass
es kaputt geht krieg ich das net er können voll was meint ihr leute ob amazon das checkt
wenn ich das zurückschicke weil sie die gucken sich das so genau an man kann es mit alkohol
ablösen ja tatsächlich das könnte man machen aber guck mal hier also man kriegt das also
man muss es ja eigentlich auch nur man muss es ja eigentlich auch nur hier oben irgendwo
abkriegen hier guck mal hier ist die schraube hier ist die schraube hier ist die schraube
wisst ihr was man sticht da einfach durch man sticht da einfach durch das ja noch besser
man muss es gar nicht abmachen man muss wissen wo die schraube ist guck mal man sticht da
einfach durch scheiß drauf ok ok ok aber jetzt viel interessanter ist welche pins sind was
welche pins sind was also wir haben auf jeden fall hier schon mal einen ich muss auch kurz
meine gunner optics scope scopeen kann die mit dem headset richtig aufziehen was steht
denn da drauf d0 das ist bestimmt gpia 0 das ist bestimmt pin 0 das braucht man das braucht
man um das der in das der in flash modus geht ach ja übrigens und leute was wir hier machen
das ist aktuell alles ungefährlich also hier ist kein strom dran oder sonst was aber mach
den scheiß nicht irgendwie damit strom dran ja und auch seid danach vorsichtig also auch
zum flaschen muss man da kein strom anmachen wer kann das alles flaschen ohne strom also
ohne main strom ok was leute kennt sich einer mit multimeter gedöns aus wir müssen messen
was ground ist habe ich schon nie mal also hier ist tx rx das ist schon mal eine sache
die nice ist d0 ist gpio 0 der ist bestimmt absichtlich da weil man muss gpio 0 auf
ground packen dass der in den flash modus geht ja deswegen es ist die null die null
ist wahrscheinlich gleich wie gpio 0 das muss man auf ground packen dass das ja dass er
in flash modus geht also wir müssen testen was ist wie sie sie also sprichprogramm strom
her welcher pin ist strom und kann man das vielleicht irgendwo erkennen ok chat jetzt
müssen wir bexy bexy chat machen ihr müsst mir erklären wie das geht ich werde mal gleich
mal multimeter holen fahrt scheiße ich muss gucken wo ich das habe und dann testen wir
das wenn viel kaputt machen können wir nichts wichtig ist schon mal das tx rx dransteht tx
rx brauchen wir tx rx ist jetzt gleich man erkennt es nicht so richtig aber dass da
ich habe es abgemacht es muss gleich wieder dranlöten ja grau ist rx weiß ist tx aber
man muss es vertauschen man muss es vertauschen aber da steht auch was drauf oder bringt das
was wenn man das abmacht da ist ein schalter guck mal da ist ein ach nee das ist der das
ist der schalter das ist der schalter zum an und aus machen links und rechts max ich
liebe diese kamer durch tanke mehr wird ja da ist ok was der metallschirm des wehland
dingens ist sicher ground wo ist wo ist das wehland dingens ich sehe es gar nicht hier
drunter wahrscheinlich man die wehland das ist ja meistens so eine schlange ah guck
mal hier hinten hier hinten haben wir auch noch was die sache ist jetzt die ist das überhaupt
1.3 ist das überhaupt in sp 2 sp 266 266 suchen wir mal danach also was steht da drauf
cuckoo cuckoo z0 v1 1 das moment also mir ist das ding da müssen wir kurz danach suchen
cuckoo es cuckoo z0 v1.1 cuckoo alles klar ja
man findet aus irgendwelchen gründen da was mit sp 32 das finde ich schon mal interessant
google ist da meistens relativ intuitiv ok sp 266 z0 1.1 1.3 nee was habe ich gesagt
oben steht was von 1.3 ach du große kacke was ist das da ich hole gleich mal multimeter
dann messen wir das ja wir flaschen das was das flaschen soll dass man keine china cloud
mehr braucht und weil ich wissen will wie es geht ok wir gehen jetzt einfach mal davon
aus in sp 28 ich muss mal kurz mal multimeter suchen und dann müssen wir müssen wir messer
ausstellen zu machen gleich wieder da wo habe ich denn das wo habe ich denn das
wo habe ich denn das wo habe ich denn das wo habe ich denn das wo habe ich denn das wo
Leute ich finde es nicht vielleicht ist es hier in dem Schrank drin ich gucke mal kurz
ob es hier drin ist ah hier ist es exzellent es ist jetzt kein ultra fluke high-end ding
was ich hier habe so ein china teil aber das reicht dafür ich mache mal kurz euch wieder
auf die kamera es geht ehrlich gesagt ich weiß wer hat es gerade gefragt micha es geht
erst mal zu gucken ob es funktioniert wo habe ich hier die passenden so ich habe da noch
hier mehr dinger gucken ob das damit tut so leute jetzt müsste er jetzt müsste er back
siten jetzt müsste er backsiten jetzt jetzt kommen elektronische sache sachen wo ich
keinen plan von hab also wir müssen jetzt wir müssen jetzt messen einmal wo krone ist
und einmal wo wcc ist wie auch immer man das macht ich habe wirklich keinen platzen
schimmer also backseat backseat chat erst mal hier anschließen also an was an was müssen
wir noch anschließen also dass das schwarze ding kommt auf jeden fall schon mal da dran
so viel so viel kriege ich schon mal hin so und das rote ding kommt jetzt irgendwo anders
dran das ist multimeter ohne schiena also ich vermute mal dass wir das so wollen wollen
wir das so in der config chat wollen wir das in der config yes ok so so und jetzt und jetzt
wollen wir das hier wahrscheinlich auf auf was wollen wir das überhaupt auf auf spannung
auf was wollen wir das ah widerstand was ist das das da das ist das kleinste oder das
kleinste yes ok ok das sind übrigens nicht die gleichen sehe ich gerade kann man das
jetzt zusammen machen und testen ob es geht also was ist wenn ich das jetzt zusammen mache
dann ist wenig ok und nach was gucke ich jetzt ich muss mal gucken dass ich das passende
gegenstück hierfür finde ja wartet mal
also exzellent also die anzeige sollte was im niedrigen ombereich auftauchen ok und
das bedeutet dann was oder das ist ja big brain heute chat collaboration ok also da
kennt ihr da irgendwas drauf jetzt nehme ich muss es muss so machen dass ihr das seht so
ok also irgendjemand meinte wlan wlan wäre e-ground meint ihr das auch chat und was ist
was ist wlan davon was ist hier von wlan das hier ist das relay hier ist das wlan das
ist die das hier ist die wlan antenne leute das hier ist die wlan antenne das hier ist
die wlan antenne seht ihr es so das metallgehäuse dort ok also ok ok ok was mache ich jetzt
soll ich jetzt soll ich jetzt jeden pin mit jedem pin probieren
jeden pin zum gehäuse also ich halte quasi das hier unten ans gehäuse ok oder
da tut sich nix da tut sich nix also an das weh was weiß ich denn was das wlan gehäuse
ist das hier ist die das hier ist die antenne vom wlan das hier
es muss ein esp 2866 sein theoretisch theoretisch man kann da gar nicht richtig checken
wisst ihr da bin ich zu doof für für sowas da habe ich keinen plan da habe ich echt kein
plan von ich habe gehofft da ist eine beschriftung drauf die metallische abschirmung über
der antenne ihr die hier meint ihr das da das ding das da warum öffnest du nicht einfach
das datenblatt lull dann sag mir mal welches datenblatt ich dir öffnen soll keck weh
kann ich da mein finger so drauf machen ist das irgendwie schlimm
ja die seriennummer alter leute viel spaß beim googeln der seriennummer weil jetzt habe
ich die show gemacht also nicht der krokodil klemme doch aber die kann ich dann auch gar
nicht ranklemmen du meinst hier das ding dran habe ich habe ich moment habe ich habe ich
irgendwo so was habe ich ob das quick ob das was geht ist da irgendwie ob das so geht oh
nee also setke viewer du musst davon ausgehen wenn du mir was schreibst im chat ich habe
davon absolut keine ahnung von elektronik in dem kram also du musst mir genau sagen
was wo well überhaupt also meinst du
also hier ist rxdxd0 das sind die runden türme ja hier sind ganz
viel runde runde türme die sache ist nur die ich meine ich kann mal da drunter gucken
höh machen wir das mal ab wir machen einfach mal das ding da ab komm wir machen wir das
mal raus außer da ah so also ah ha ha ha beschriftung beschriftung in 2020 das einfach mal eine
beschriftung drauf lull ground hier round ich kann es legit nicht lesen äh könnt ihr
das lesen moment wo ist meine scope wo ist meine krasse scopes brille ist zu klein aber
ich kann es echt nicht lesen ground was heißt das andere 1 0 1 rx what the fuck nee das steckt
halb im gehäuse man kann das nicht lesen ground ok also wir wissen schon mal dass das da ground
ist das da ganz rechts ist ground ok das heißt im prinzip es können wir jetzt mal ausprobieren
also sprich wenn ich jetzt weiß was ground ist ground ist ja irgendwie meine scope brille
ist das da auf jeden fall so und jetzt mache ich was da passiert nix kann ich jetzt irgendwie
was irgendwie überprüfen ob das was tut also ich suche da wo Strom 3,3 volt dann drauf
ist was das warum leitet es zwischen ground und dem hier warum leitet es zwischen ground
und dem und dem metall habt ihr eine ahnung warum warum warum warum was sind das da was
was was ist das da aus irgendwelchen gründen gibt es eine verbindung zwischen ground und
dem da was ist das ich suche nicht ich suche nicht ground ground hab ich ich suche äh
3,3 volt so also wie kriege ich das guck mal hier kann man sich das irgendwie anhand
dieser dinge hier ableiten ich mein wir können es einfach ausprobieren wenn man den scheiß
ja lesen könnte wir googeln einfach mal nach dem kram was da drauf steht wir lesen wir
googeln einfach mal was da drauf steht also wir haben eins mit ich muss mal kurz das licht
im home assistant volle pulle machen dass ich ich habe mein arbeitszimmer licht schon volle
pulle ok mehr geht nicht also ich kann hier nur was zum teufel steht da drauf also rxtx
das habe ich das kenne ich so so und jetzt muss ich irgendwas anderes iow oder sowas
ich kann das ich kann das nicht erkennen was da bei den anderen sachen noch drauf steht
guck mal da steht da steht ja noch was das da unten heißt rx und da oben steht irgendwas
eins null eins oder sowas iow eins oder sowas äh licky pray nein das könnte man nicht machen
das ding geht komplett über 3,3 volt zum flaschen also deswegen ich gehe da auch nicht
mit netzspannung dran
ne ne ne ne sieht da nicht aus da steht leider halt auch überhaupt nichts drauf auf dem ding
da steht hinten steht irgendwie noch da steht cuckoo z null v11 und 13 was auch immer und
vorne steht irgendwas drauf mit xhx 2026 what the fuck das ist absolut nichts sagen leute
ich hab noch ne idee wisst ihr was könnte das sein was meint ihr denn warte mal was meint
ihr könnte das das hier noch was ist denn das hier
das ist was sind denn das hier für dinger
jaja multimeter
so jetzt machen wir mal ne andere frage wie würde ich denn überhaupt mit meinem multimeter
irgendwie raus bekommen was wie sie sie welcher pin wie sie sie ist
kannst du mal den dicken schwarzen block zeigen den hier
hier cuckoo 5 v z cuckoo z null
achso das hier ist das relay das ist das relay das ist das relay ziemlich sicher das also
es geht um das ding hier das ist der controller
das dazu findet man auch nix voll auf den sack
jetzt ist es ausgegangen poggers poggers in the chat
indem du an crown gehst und dann random pins durchtestet bis du durchgang hast also sprich
das ist das ist schon richtig was ich hier eingestellt habe
also sprich das ist schon richtig was ich hier eingestellt habe
so auf was muss ich meinen multimeter stellen ist das richtig so
das ist eine gute idee wir gucken mal wir gucken mal das lay out von der sp 1111 an
das ist das ist gut das ist eine gute idee
ja ob das das gleiche ist
ne das sieht ganz anders aus just chatting nicht das falsche just chatting
doch das sieht ähnlich aus das sieht ähnlich aus
das würde nämlich bedeuten also wenn das da stimmt wenn dieses bild hier stimmt
wenn dieses bild hier stimmt dann ist 3,3 volt das hier guckt mal also wenn dieses bild
da stimmt dann ist 3,3 volt das da das hier
also sprich das heißt ich gehe jetzt mal auf auf ground
das muss natürlich jetzt komplett auf der anderen seite sein exzellent
ach du scheiße ich mache das jetzt also das da das da müsste
monac s ist ja was ich löte das jetzt einfach dran und gucke ob es geht
naja wo soll ich die klemme denn ich hab eine klemme aber ich weiß nicht wo ich die klemme
dran klemmen soll ich meine wo soll ich eine klemme dran
klemmen kannst du knicken da fehlt die dritte hand ich habe hier sogar so ein teil
ok ok ich weiß wie wir das machen machen das jetzt so
so und jetzt ok ihr müsst jetzt was passieren wenn das
hier wirklich wie cc ist was müsste man multimeter machen wenn ich
das jetzt richtig erwische ist das dann überhaupt was machen
ich glaube ich bin auch abgerutscht
also ich habe ich habe ehrlich gesagt kein plan aber ist hier was ich meine es kann
ja nichts kaputt gehen es kann ja nichts kaputt gehen ich löte das jetzt einfach mal dran
und gucke ob es funktioniert kann er nicht was soll großartig passieren ja
ich weiß mehr als nicht angehen kann es ja nicht mehr als mehr als nicht angehen kann
es ja nicht es kann ja nicht kaputt gehen so exzellenter plan so machen wir das
gut da muss ich mir gerade noch mal die einleitung angucken erst mal die musik erst mal die kirby
musik neu starten sonst geht hier ja nichts da wird nichts verpolt ich weiß so klar ich
das passt schon es kann einfach nur nicht angehen im zweifelsfall würde ich sagen ich
habe drei stück jaja das ding das teil wäre ich wahrscheinlich immer verwenden also ich
muss jetzt erst mal das letzte angucken was ich geflasht habe das letzte war dieses
fack das teil hier bbs d34 das moda genau so da muss ich mich mal kurz schauen das war
nämlich ein richtig gutes bild ich weiß welcher crowd ist jaja das weiß ich
irgendwas mit dns oder so hieß das diese seite
pins das war nämlich der alte
anderer
ja genau die seite habe ich gesagt genau weil das war das letzte war ich geflasht
habe das auch wunderbar da muss ich jetzt erst mal überlegen wie habe ich denn das
gemacht also tx auf rx rx auf tx auf ground man musste man musste beim sp 32 musste man
glaube ich unbedingt ground noch auf gp au1 machen sonst ging es glaube ich netz ja gp
au genau gp au0 muss auf crown sonst funktioniert es nicht ok dann machen wir das mal wir löten
es jetzt einfach mal dran und gucken was passiert excellent guter plan so war das exquisite also
zack zack zack wohl wird man das am besten dran da weil ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
wo das rauskommt aber hier dran zu löten wird absolut eklig ich habe auch meine lötspitzen
nicht da ich habe nur die normale also ich vermute mal dass das da vcc ist wir probierens
wir probierens wir probierens soll ich war mal kurz ein bisschen platz ich war mal kurz
ein bisschen platz also man sieht übrigens meistens schon ob es funktioniert wenn man
das usb einsteckt und das blinkt die sache ist nur die ich habe keine ahnung ob das in
irgendeiner art und weise leds drauf hat und man sieht dass es blinkt wo habe ich denn das
rausgenommen leute ich bin blind wo fehlt es so der kram kommt auch weg der hier kommt
auch weg weil ich brauche ein bisschen platz wenn ich den kram jetzt hier dran löte gut
also zack zack zack lötstells an start so chat postchamp mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert
hier anschalten stinkt es erstmal also ich werde jetzt zuerst mal ich werde jetzt zuerst
mal gut das kann ich das ok ne das machen wir so also den machen wir an kronz der kommt
an kronz der kommt an kronz der hier kommt an vermutlich vermeintlich vcc das müsste
schon mal reichen dass das ding angeht von der theorie her wozu ist diese stahlwolle
das guck dass wenn man hier das lötzchen hat ein bisschen lötzchen zack zack zack wenn
das dran hängt kannst du es damit abmachen so also po alter wie soll ich den scheiß
da dran kriegen das ist ja mal voll für ein arsch ok wir fangen mal mit wie sie sie an
wie sie sie sollte relativ wie sie sein falls das wie sie sie ist da ist sogar da ist sogar
ein bisschen was dran da ist sogar ein bisschen was wir machen jetzt nur wir machen nur wie
sie sie dran und nur kronz und gucken dann ob es funktioniert wahrscheinlich nieg ich
jetzt meine nase gleich ich muss das so machen ok es ist halbwegs fest so und jetzt auf die
andere seite irgendwie kronz ist das für gefuddelt wollen die mich rollen wollen die
mich rollen geht wieder ab gleich sage ich euch so da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen lötzchen
vorher drauf machen da geht ja gar nichts dran ok jetzt ist ein bisschen was drauf da muss
ich jetzt kronz dran machen das hält doch im leben hält das nicht alter meine güte
ich hab ich hab zu wenig hände er hab zu wenig hände wird doch im leben nichts da ist ja
überhaupt nichts dran ha ha ha ist das jetzt da dran oder hängt das irgendwo anders würde
sagen das ist dran ok ok ok jetzt nicht so sehr belasten den ganzen die ganze konstruktion
mal schauen ob das irgendwas ob das in den lebenszeichen von sich gibt jetzt mal gucken
ob das in den lebenszeichen ich brauche usb kabel und ich brauche usb kabel so lasst du
mal vorher was gucken hat das ding irgendwelche leds hat das ding irgendwelche leds die leuchten
könnten ich sehe jetzt nichts wir machen jetzt mal das licht aus jetzt mal das licht
aus dass wir es gleich besser blinken sehen ok mal gucken ob das ich hab wirklich kein
blasser schimmer ob das so wir machen das jetzt erstmal ein raspberry pi rein
rixi ja ab und zu mal sauber machen ist nicht verkehrt richtig geddo setup so also guck
mal mal provisorische setup vor allem oh nee das ist fucking mini usb wo hab ich denn
einen mini usb anschluss mini usb ich fass es nicht so toll
mini usb ich hab was gefunden mini usb ok jetzt schauen wir mal ob es angeht jetzt
bin ich ja mal echt gespannt also das ding geht an ist klar aber ob hier was leuchtet
müssen wir jetzt mal kurz gucken klar hat er irgendwas geleuchtet
es muss ja auch nicht unbedingt led max aufpassen ok ich muss alles anlöten ich muss alles
anlöten da sieht man nichts habt ihr irgendwas leuchten sehen beim einstecken
ne oder außer des da das ist klar da können wir das wieder anmachen ok also wir machen
das jetzt einfach wir tun einfach mal so als wissen wir welcher anschluss was ist ok
mal den kram hier weg ok also was brauchen wir als nächstes wir haben jetzt ground und
vcc dran dann brauchen wir jetzt hier kommst du mal her dann brauchen wir jetzt das hier
ist man kann es ja kaum erkennen also das graue ist rx so und was ich am anfang öfters
verkehrt gemacht hat man muss rx auf tx löten und tx auf rx so also ich hab gesagt was grau
ist grau ist rx werden wir noch blitze sehen sehr unwahrscheinlich
rx rx ok rx muss dann also auf machen mal kurz ein bisschen hier was dran also das muss
dann auf was habe ich gesagt ich bin übelst vergesslich gerade auch das war knapp alter
ich wäre fast an lütkolben reingekommen monka es beinahe jetzt brandblase gegeben ich sag
es euch beinahe hier mr blasers am start gewesen brandblasers ok so das hier ist tx
kommst du mal her hier fehlt echt zwei hände gerade so jetzt mal gucken dass wir das da
hinkriegen oder kommst du mal her ok ok ok wir haben es dran pause champ wir schließen
den raspberry an versuchen einfach zu flaschen easy wird zwar nicht gehen aber man kann es
probieren wir flaschen jetzt einfach jolo flasch erstmal hier ausmachen den kolben
der kolben der kolben wird ab lassen wir den kolben erst mal abkühlen so und ist das alles
noch dran ja gachi bass ok jetzt ist halt die frage ob wir noch gpio auf ground machen
müssen gpio 0 auf ground oder nicht das können wir uns aber mal abgucken hier der typ der
hat es ja gemacht bei der anderen steckdose so ground also ich meine er hat 0 draufgeschrieben
ground und 0 brücken um den flash modus einzuleihen ok also wird es jetzt nicht funktionieren
machen wir gleich noch wir gehen jetzt mal auf den raspberry pi drauf pi add 2147 so
wir müssen erstmal hier das esp tool installieren mal gucken ob es das über das repo gibt also
das ist das was man zum flaschen braucht wenn es klappt dann absoluter big brain move ja
guck mal das esp tool ist drauf esp tool yes ok esp tool tasmota download tasmota releases
wenn das klappt ist richtig big brain move angesagt ich weiß aber nicht ob ich mich
traue das ding wieder zusammen zu pappen und wieder an die steckdose anzuschließen tasmota
bin hallo tasmota bin ist jetzt auch das richtige release die seite ist so groß ja du weißt
oh fuck meine ips geliegt schon wieder die hacker mans hacken gleich äh localhost safe
ach moment ich brauch das gar nicht auf dem rechner ich brauch das auf dem raspberry pi
ok esp tool erstmal gucken wo das ganze fd tty usb esp tool tasmota ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht wie das funktioniert aus dem kopf schon so lange her backup wir können
mal ein backup von der current firmware probieren ob das ob das geht ich meine wenn das backup
von der firmware geht dann ist es halt schon mensch was achso post post jam post post
post post jam post post nein das geht nicht post jam post jam post jam post jam post jam
es gibt keinen riesen schlag da kann ich schlagen sind 3,3 volt was soll da was passieren ok
wir müssen noch wir müssen noch gpio 0 anschließen an ground ja den ganzen müll
braucht man doch eigentlich gar nicht oder man braucht einfach man braucht einfach esp
tool dankeschön für die ganzen subs übrigens leute ich hab nur die die helft nicht gesehen
das gilt ihr gleich den pizzer ist auch noch gar nicht am pc angeschlossen ok das wird
so nicht funktionieren wir haben es noch nicht gepridged ich will mal über das kommando
schon mal hinschreiben def usb tty usb 0 ich weiß nicht warum das chat so scharf drauf
ist dass es gleich puff macht davon abgesehen sneaky boy zwei monat dankeschön excellent
subscription da kann überhaupt nichts puff machen ok wir müssen noch die wir müssen
es noch pritschen also zack da machen wir das jetzt mal schnell also müssen ground
und gpio 0 wir gucken noch mal schnell was der dude hier gemacht hat
bestimmt nicht ich habe das bestimmt nicht richtig angeschlossen 0 0 und ground gut
0 0 und ground ist kein großartiges ding da müssen wir da gar nichts mehr dran löten
außer 0 0 zum beispiel können wieder anschmeißen ich habe ich gar nicht rüber geschaltet
i0 0 hier ist i0 0 hier ist i0 0 i0 0 wir machen jetzt trick 17 wir verbinden das einfach
machen hier so ein
So, wir müssen da ein bisschen, bisschen Lützchen dran machen
Falls ich da das mal irgendwie hinkrieg
Ich hoffe man sieht was
Sieht man was chat?
Ja, ich glaube schon
Kann aber ein bisschen was hängen bleiben
Bleibt nix hänge
Weil ich hab zu wenig Hände frei grad
Ok, exellent
So, und jetzt haben wir Trick 17
Wir nehmen den hier, wir machen den noch mal ab
Machen den noch mal ab
Und jetzt löte ich mir den mal da dran
An Ground
Der sollte eigentlich normalerweise dran sein
Dann haben wir das abgegangen
Da kann ich das nämlich einfach dran stecken
Weil man muss das nachher wieder abziehen
Wenn man das nachher nicht abzieht
Dann bootet die Kiste nämlich nicht
Das heißt man muss, man muss, GPIO 0
Muss man so temporär, temporär dran machen
Alter, ich hab zu wenig Hände
Händechamp
Ah, kack Ding, bleibst du mal so hier
So, ich brauch mehr Hände
Ich hab zu wenig Hände
Alter ich hab zu...
So, ich das ist ja voll für ein Arsch her
Wow, was habst du hier
Hier ist voll, echt voll Ghetto Setup
Ok, wisst ihr was?
Trick 17
So
Hä?
Gucken ob das schon reicht, was da dran ist
Alter, das ist, freudig, ist das freudig
Ich müsste eigentlich so bisschen Lötzinn drauf machen
Ah, ich hab gar Hand
Meine Hand reicht nicht
Ich krieg da nicht Lötzinn und Dings gleichzeitig dran
So, Postchamp, jetzt haben wir's
Es sieht zwar äußerst, ein äußerst schöne Lötz, äh, Arbeit, ja
So, zack
Ihh, das passt nicht
Warum KS, ey, das ist, das arbeitet echt alles gegen mich gerade
So, gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert
So, gut, wir haben GPIO 0
GPIO 0, Ground, Rest angeschlossen, jetzt Postchamp, ob's funktioniert, äh
Ich glaub ja nicht, ich glaub wir haben's gar nicht an VCC richtig dran
Was hast du mit meinen Händen gemacht, ich hab mit der Katz gespielt
Post, Post, Post, Post, Post, Post, Postchamp, Champ
Ich hab ne dritte Hand, aber die hab ich grad nicht da, nein, es funktioniert nicht
Fuck
Das ist schonmal der falsche Pin gewesen
Der falsche Pin
Zeig mal ein Bild von der Katze, ähm, ja
Gut, das ist der falsche Pin
Also, kann man sich da nicht so richtig drauf verlassen, dass das hier gleich ist
Ich hab jetzt so gehofft, dass das hier, dass das hier VCC ist, fuck
Okay, dann, tja
Dann überprüfen wir nochmal, ob wir prinzipiell alles richtig haben
Also, wir haben Ground auf GPIO 0, vermute ich mal, dass das das heißen soll
Aber Moment, ich muss euch umschalten
Wir haben das auf GPIO 0, wir haben, wir haben TX auf RX und RX auf, auf, ich kann's erzählen
auf TX, wir haben VCC auf, wahrscheinlich VCC, wer weiß es nicht
Und Ground auf Ground
Sogar alles relativ fest, muss man sagen
Also, das ist richtig, das ist alles richtig
Die Sache ist nur die
Wahrscheinlich ist das verkehrt
Also, wahrscheinlich ist das nicht 3,3 Volt
Chico, heißt er, heißt sie, heißt sie
Ähm, was könnten, was könnten das noch sein
Oh, Leute, Leute
Ich hab mich vertan
Ich hab, ich hab Ground nicht auf Ground, sondern auf RX gelötet, lull
Hoffentlich hab ich das Ding jetzt nicht kaputt gemacht
Ah, Quatsch, die Dinger sind robust
Geh ab
Ich hab, oh Gott
Tja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass er kaputt ist
Die Dinger sind relativ, relativ robust immer
So, jetzt müsste nur mal ein bisschen Lötz hinter hängen bleiben
Okay, ist jetzt ein bisschen was dran
Jetzt Ground, jetzt Ground
Groundchamp, wir brauchen neues Emote, Groundchamp
Okay, Groundchamp, Groundchamp ist dran
Hoffentlich ist er auch nicht mit dem anderen Pin in Verbindung
Sieht nicht so aus, Groundchamp
Okay, wo ist der Raspberry Pi
Ha, ha, ha, habt ihrs gesehen
Habt ihrs gesehen, es hat geplinkt
Habt ihrs gesehen, Leute
Es hat geplinkt
Nein, es ist nicht kaputt
Wenn es plinkt, ist es nicht kaputt
Connected
Bäm, es flasht, es flasht, Leute
In your face
So, nee, nee, das ist okay, das ist ein MB, was der flashen muss
ESP 85 ist ein ESP 86, das ist im Prinzip das gleiche
Subgifts, na wenn einer Gifts, wenn einer Subgiften müsste, dann nicht ich euch, sondern
ihr mir
Ich glaub es geht los, warum soll ich Subgiften jetzt
Ich werd vielleicht Subgiften, wenn es überhaupt nicht geklappt hätte
Okay, okay, ja, Postchamp, aber ansonsten
So, und jetzt geh ich, und jetzt, und jetzt, und jetzt, und jetzt
Was wir jetzt machen müssen, ist TAS Motor einrichten
Achtung, TAS Motor einrichten
Dazu, jetzt, jetzt kommt, jetzt muss ich, deswegen hab ich das so gemacht, dass man stecken kann
Jetzt muss ich nämlich den Pin raus machen, also Crown raus machen
So, noch mal Strom resetten
Und jetzt muss ich ans Tablet in das TAS Motor WLAN
Bäm, ich bin connected Leute, TAS Motor 1.4, stellts WLAN
Bäm, da ist die, da ist Custom Firmware am Start
Seht ihr das?
Ah ne, ihr seht ja gar nichts
Ich hab euch nicht umgeschaltet, hier, Custom Firmware, bäm
Custom Firmware
Okay, jetzt geb ich mal meine WLAN, meine WLAN Sachen ein
Ohne, ohne, dass ihr, ohne, dass ihr was sehen dürft
Das Gute ist, ich kann mich jetzt vertippen
Und ich kanns jederzeit reflaschen
So, alter meine Passwörter sind so unglaublich, so unglaublich dumm
Die bestehen zum größten Teil aus irgendwelchen aneinander gereiten Twitch Emotes
Unter anderem Lulvee bin ich gerade am tippen
Aber der Rest ist so lang, den verrate ich euch nicht
Okay, save configuration, TAS Motor Reboot
Muss jetzt in meinen Rauder gucken, was das Ding für eine DHCP IP bekommt
IP, DHCP Server, Leases, wartet mal
147 kann das sein, TAS Motor, Progas, da sind wir, bäm
Blinkt das wenn man an ausmacht, guck mal es blinkt wenn man an ausmacht
Ich muss mal kurz hören, ob das Relay schaltet
Das Relay schaltet nicht, aber die Einstellungen stimmen ja auch hinten und vorne nicht
By the way, die Einstellungen sind ja auch komplett falsch
Ich muss jetzt die Einstellungen mir auswählen hier
Wie heißt der Hersteller, hab schon wieder vergessen
GoSund, SP211, das da, GoSund
So, dann geht mir jetzt auf Configuration Sample
Nee, warte mal, wo ist das immer versteckt, other, ja
Save, ah nee ich hab Activate vergessen, ich hab Activate vergessen
Ist das ein mechanisches Relay, fragt mich was, wahrscheinlich oder
Ja ist es, das macht klick klick, macht klick klick wenn du, wenn du das schaltest
Klick klick, hat sich das jetzt gemerkt, ich Activate noch mal
Ok, jetzt noch mal hören, ah ich hörs ich hörs
Ich halt euch mal dran, ich glaub aber nicht, dass ihr das auch hört
Das ist ultra, ultra leise
Hört ihr was, absolut nichts, ja ich hab mein neues Geld an
Ich hab mein neues Geld an, ok, nice, nice, aber es funktioniert
Nice, nice, so und jetzt kommt der spannende Part, den Scheiß wieder zusammenzubauen
Ich muss den Grad wieder zusammenbauen
Ok, geflasht ist es, alles klar, zack können wir wieder abmachen
So erstmal wieder ablöten, auf Lötkolben, werd warm
Der schaltet sich immer runter nach einer Weile
Excellent so, hätten wir das
So und jetzt muss ich wieder zusammenbauen
Ok jetzt wirds ein bisschen komplizierter
Wo ist mein Tablet, mein Tablet mit Twitch Chat
Endelig, oh mein Gott
Chat sag mal was, ich muss gucken ob mein Chat Vorschau wieder funktioniert
Ne, ah ja was, was, ok passt, Chat Vorschau funktioniert, ne so war das
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen, nicht mehr ganz so konzentratet
Alter Kirby Musik ist ja gut, nicht so ausrasten
Oh das ist ein bisschen verbogen hier, mach ich zuerst rein
Bisschen verbogen, muss ich mal kurz zurückbiegen
Das ESD Arm war ein Lullwee, hast du dir gemerkt wie die Pin Belegung war, ne aber wir haben
den Stream wo wir nachgucken können
So passt, sitzt passt wackelt und hat Luft hat man aber immer gesagt
Gut, das haben wir
So viele Teile sinds ja gar nicht was wir brauchen
So viele Teile sinds ja gar nicht
Warum warten das hier, das muss ich jetzt im Stream nachgucken
War das so oder auf der anderen Seite
Das muss so gewesen sein, weil das passt andersrum nicht rein
Ich glaub das passt andersrum nicht rein
Genau andersrum passt das nicht, weil dann die Löcher hier nicht passen, oder?
Würde das andersrum, ich muss mal kurz überprüfen ob das andersrum theoretisch auch passen würde
Doch, doch würde es
Ne würde es nicht, haha, die haben das richtig rum gemacht, guck mal
Die Chinesen sind schlau, die wissen dass die das auch falsch rum machen
Guck hier ist so ein Pin und dieser Pin geht nur
Der Pin geht nur wenn das richtig rum ist
So, dann holen wir mal den Pogchamp wieder raus
Und Pogchampen mal ne Runde, äh die Lötkoll machen wir mal aus
Schmeißen das mal weg
So, also
Ne, das ist auf jeden Fall richtig jetzt
Deswegen ist das hier oben recht praktisch, da kann man einfach so machen
So, äh Schraube, wo ist die Schraube, da
Machs gut 1337
Ich kenn mich, mir fällt jetzt noch die Schraube irgendwie rein, ich muss noch mal aufmachen
Auch bisschen überdreht, aber passt
Knöpfe gehen, Knöpfe gehen, hier Kriegsspuren, Wunden
War echt, der Stream ist noch nicht fertig, jetzt muss ich erstmal gucken ob es geht
Chat nicht abhauen, äh das war, das war so ne, das hier auch irgendwie verpolungsgeschützt
Dass das nur in eine Richtung reinpasst
Ich glaub, ich glaub so war das
Also ich glaube, ich glaube das rote war da
Das rote war da und das schwarze war da
Gut ich mein hier steht, hier steht L und N dran, aber auf die China Beschriftung geb
ich ja nix
Ich hätt mir das mal markieren sollen, aber ich glaube
Wir gucken noch mal im Stream wie rum es dran war
Wir gucken noch mal kurz im Stream nach wie rum es dran muss
Ich hab's doch, ich hab's doch hier
Ist egal, das mag sein, dass das egal ist, aber ich schließ das so an wie es gewesen
ist
Ist auch nicht schwierig rauszukriegen, wir gucken einfach im Stream wo ich's aufgemacht
hab
So Cocktail ist offen, so also ich zeig's ja irgendwo
Alter hab ich darum gestruggelt ey
Mach ich die Kratzaktion erstmal
Also ne da hab ich schon ab
Also
Auf der Seite wo das Relay ist
Unten, dann das schwarze
Okay auf der Seite wo das Relay ist also da
Also so
So ne
Ja so war das dann
Also ich geh mal zurück
Also so guckt
So
So müsste das ne
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehen hab was ich da gemacht hab
Ja
Excellent gut
Also wenn sich das jetzt gut zumachen lässt und so dann trau ich mich das in die Steckdose
zu stecken
Ich muss es ja nicht angreifen, ich kanns ja remod über das
Das Motor schalten
Ist so durch
So
Und jetzt das andere oben
Alter ist das nicht magnetisch das Ding
Ich sag dir mir fällt das noch rein ich hol mir jetzt ne Zange und mach das raus
Sonst fällt mir nicht, ich kenn mich mir fällt das rein und dann krieg ichs nimmer
raus
So Operation geklückt
Das ist aber das ist nicht magnetisch irgendwie
So
Da oben in die Eck
So was sagen die Elektriker
Passt doch so
Rot an L
Schwarz an N
Und eigentlich muss es auch so gewesen sein
Und jetzt muss was einmal drehen
Oder so rum
So rum
Drehen
Jetzt kann man es zumachen
So gucken dass wir es richtig einfädeln
Haben wir es richtig eingefädelt
Würd eigentlich schon sagen dass wir es richtig eingefädelt haben
Es geht ja auch nur in eine Richtung zu
Ich hab blödsinn mit Play, das ist überhaupt kein Ding das darf sich jeder auch kaufen
Für privaten Anwendungszwecken
Also so wirklich gut zugehen tut das nicht
Das war aber so
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass das so war
Geht das nicht
Wo hängts denn
Wo wo wo hängts
Das ging auch nicht wirklich gut aus ja das auf das stimmt
Meinst du da geht es auch nicht wirklich gut zu wenn es schon nicht wirklich gut aufging
Das geht nicht
Seht ihr das schwarze Kabel das muss da vorbei würde ich sagen
Was ist das Problem
Was ist das Problem warum geht das nicht
Also das muss einfacher zugehen das hängt irgendwo
Oder auch nicht
Ganz ehrlich ich sehe nicht wo das hängen könnte
Das ist eigentlich okay
Wisst ihr was
Okay guck mal da hängt da hängt nix das geht einfach nur schlecht zu
Das geht einfach nur schlecht zu da hängt nix
Das ist einfach nur übelst im Arsch
Sag mal wie war das eigentlich zu war das hier drin
Ja das geht hier gar nicht
Jetzt jetzt
Oder auch nicht
Das war ja schon beim aufmachen kacke ne
Das war ja schon beim aufmachen mega scheiße
Was ist das
Das geht nicht warum geht denn das nicht
Was hat das für Schmerzen das hängt nirgendswo
Warum muss das jetzt an der Stelle rumspacken
Auf der anderen Seite hier guck mal hier geht es total easy rein
Da nicht was ist denn das
Tasmota flashen ja wir haben wir haben gerade schon Tasmota geflasht
Wisst ihr was sein kann dass ich es verbogen habe ein bisschen
Da ich das erstmal wieder ein bisschen gerad biegen muss
Woran genau hängst du
Wo hängst du dran alter da ist doch nix
Hol die schraube raus das ist tatsächlich eine gute idee
Die schrauben sind die schrauben sind relativ locker die sind das nicht
Ich bin mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt echt nicht sicher woran das scheiß was mit
der hänge wir haben es schon nicht gescheit aufgekriegt
Die schrauben sind das nicht hier gibt es
Fack alter kann doch nicht sein dass es immer zugeht
Anfälle mit diesem kack Ding
Ich meine auf der Seite geht es easy zu hier
Gar kein Ding aber hier hängts und ich weiß nicht wo
Keine Ahnung wo das hängt
Ja ich sehe es ja auch nicht
Hängt das da oben irgendwo
Ich will es jetzt noch ausprobieren
Ich habe keine Ahnung woran das scheiß jetzt hängt
Ja ich habe es geflasht bekommen
Also chat mal ganz ehrlich
Stöß mal an woran wird das hängen
Das ergibt für mich keinen Sinn
Man kann auch kaum reingucken das ist das Problem
Richtig
Also das scheint nicht, das hängt hier neben.
Hier gehts überall rein.
Hier hängt das irgendwo.
Das ist ja schon quasi fast drin.
Da ist doch... da kann doch nix im...
Woran hängts denn?
Ich hab das bestimmt verbogen beim aufmachen.
Also hier hängt nix, hier, also die Seite ist ok, hier hängt nix.
Hier hängts, hier.
Da hängts, da wo es verbogen ist hängts.
Neee, mit dem Hammer bringt nix, mit dem Hammer mach ich nur noch mehr kaputt.
Hier hängts irgendwo.
Ich weiß aber nicht warum.
Es passt, es passt genau drauf.
So und jetzt, und jetzt gehts nur nicht rein.
Warum nicht?
Wann fuckt mich das ab, ich will jetzt ausprobieren ob es funktioniert.
Die Kabel sind auch keine im Weg, also... ist eigentlich genug Platz?
Tja... chat, ich weiß net.
Das ist ok, wir gucken uns das noch mal kurz an.
also wo geht das hier rein gar nicht gar nicht das geht hier nirgendswo rein
das könnte nur hängen hier am relay oder so vielleicht hier dazwischen ok ich gehe
mal davon aus dass ich das zu stark verbogen habe
vielleicht mache ich vielleicht mache ich das mal ab die ecke die hier total verbogen ist
ich mache ich einfach mal die ecke ab die hier total verbogen ist ich hole mal kurz die zange
so mal gucken was wir da nehmen
wir probieren es erstmal gerade zu machen ok
so kommt halbwegs hin so hier hin nehmen haben wir auch noch eine die absolut gar nicht mehr
gerade ist so haben wir die ganze scheiß mal weg ja ja ich habe schon um 180 grad gedreht ich
habe schon um 180 grad gedreht das musste das war auch ursprünglich um 180 grad gedreht
das hängt hier an der ecke
und ich habe das passt überall außer an dieser ecke
vor allem woran um alles in der welt hängt das auch
ich mein guck mal es geht wunderbar zu außer hier für den sub ok wisst ihr was ich jetzt mal
probieren ich meine es war zwar so rum drauf würde es denn so rum drauf gehen
ne post jam das war andersrum also ich ich weiß genau dass es andersrum war
ok ok die muss ich auf jeden fall mit heißkleber zu kleben klein
so probieren wir mal aus ob es funktioniert würde ich sagen zwar ein bisschen ist zwar
ein bisschen lidiert ne ich weiß genau dass das guckt mal das war definitiv andersrum vorher
schaut mal
guck das guck guck guck das war verdreht und so ist es jetzt nicht so ist es jetzt nicht
na gut wie dem auch sei wie dem auch sei ich probiere das jetzt mal aus allerdings schalte
ich die steckdosenleiste remote ich greife das nicht an wer weiß was da los ist immer
kurz also 100 prozentig trauen durch dem ding nicht muss man also ich schalte jetzt
das eine tas motor mit der anderen tas motor ich mach da ich mach gar nichts dran ich mach
einfach nur an koge ich bin grad paar feierball regeln da will ich ja ganz schön dieses ok
das ist die steckdosenleiste an die ich jetzt dran stecke nicht wundern ja also das ist
nicht das ist nicht die das ist nicht die das ist über die wie ich jetzt einschalte
die kabel die andersrum angeschlossen
was das ding sieht von beiden seiten gleich aus na evil chicken also das ding ups ich
habe es zugemacht m player also hier guck mal das ding sieht von beiden seiten gleich
aus ich habe extra im stream noch mal nachgeguckt also das ding sieht von beiden seiten gleich
aus also das da das da und innen drin auch
ne oben steht der text drauf auf einer seite das hier meinste so hier steht text drauf
ok schauen wir mal mal gucken dass ich das richtig rum habe ok ok hier steht der text
hier steht der text so und da ist das so da wo der text steht ist das schwarze kabel links
irgendwie na ok ist wirklich falsch rum guck mal ist wirklich falsch ich zeig's euch mal
das da muss auf der seite sein na gut ok das ist jetzt easy fix
noch mal raus wir gucken jetzt erstmal nicht dass ich es jetzt falsch mach wir gucken erstmal
dass ich es jetzt nicht falsch mach aber nice gesehen evil chicken also da da ist der text
ok ne das wäre auch so nicht abgebrannt ok excellent da ist der text da ist der text
und jetzt ist das schwarze moment richtig ist falsch rum ja das ist falsch rum richtig
der feil ich guck's mir jetzt grad an der feil ist ja ja ist falsch rum du meinst ac
nicht dc ok dann machen wir das ganze nochmal anders rum achso ja ich wollte euch dazu gucken
dass brauchst du nicht ich mach das aber trotzdem
moment mal ich bin ich bin echt verwirrt gerade ich bin echt grad hartkorb ist es doch richtig
rum das ist doch richtig rum oder
ja das ist richtig rum da da ist der text da ist der text die kabel sind anders geführt
ja ok scheiß drauf ich machs jetzt ich machs jetzt richtig ich mach ich machs jetzt wieder
rum und es war jetzt ja gedreht aber gedreht gehts lustigerweise nicht weißt du was scheiß
drauf was geht was nicht geht einfach zu und gut ist ok also dann schließen wir das mal
kurz an also wie gesagt leute nicht daran rumfuddeln wenn es irgendwie auf ist und auch
nicht nicht irgendwie dran greifen oder so das ist mir jetzt auch zu heikel die ganze
geschichte ich steck das jetzt in eine steckdose leiste die ich remote schalten kann mach das
an und dann ist gut ja erst mal ein lötkolben raus machen weil guck mal das ist auch überhaupt
nicht mehr fest ja also das muss ich mit heißkleber machen und ganz im ernst die werde ich nicht
mehr verwenden das mache ich jetzt nur zum ausprobieren ob alles funktioniert das werde
ich das ding ist mir viel zu viel gebastelt also da habe ich echt kein keine kein wie
soll ich sagen also kein gutes gefühl bei das ding irgendwie da drin laufen zu lassen
im haus ja ok ich rück euch mal kurz hin also ihr seht die ist aus ist jetzt drin ist die
ist drin oder nicht ne alter die passt halt mal richtig nahe hier keck das china china
in china alter what the fuck hat das den grund dass das rum das nicht reinpasst außer dass
china das china sachen das nicht unbedingt so genau nehmen mit muss passen mit dem hammer
ist klar ich halte mal alles aus wobei usb lasse ich an vielleicht ist einfach nur der
ein bisschen im arsch hier passt ok easy warum auch immer logik logik muss man nicht verstehen
hier passt jetzt die sieht schon hartkorb mitgenommen aus ne schieb das noch ein bisschen
weiter rüber die sieht schon hartkorb mitgenommen aus ok welche muss ich einschalten eins ist
jetzt an an die falsche richtung andere 5 4 ok easy funktioniert funktioniert guckt
hat gerade moment ich muss euch mal umschalten ich mache das von einem anderen rechner aus
dann könnt ihr könnt ihr das sehen
der verbindet sich jetzt ins wlan und jetzt passt auf passt auf ich schalte es mal vom
anderen aus an aus an aus easy so und jetzt testen wir noch ob das ob das mit dem strom
verbrauch messen funktioniert ich schließe jetzt mal irgendwas dran an ich schließe
jetzt mal irgendwas dran an ich habe wieder ausgeschaltet ich habe wieder ausgeschaltet
was schließe ich immer kurz dran an zum testen irgendwas was jetzt nicht also kein
heizlüfter ich schließe jetzt kein heizlüfter dran an
irgendwas mit dem normalen stecker hier jetzt wo ich mal kurz handy handy ja schließen
wir schließen einfach usb dran an ich habe doch hier irgendwo so ein doch hier irgendwo
so ein usb so normal auf usb adapter habe ja alles da
schließen wir jetzt tablet aufladen an tablet tablet auflader was adapter gedürnt so jetzt
muss ich das tablet noch anschließen tablet flupp und jetzt machen wir mal an
deckdose wo habe ich hin ja muss ich noch connecten brauchen bisschen bisschen connectet
hat so ich habe beides an handy sollte jetzt aufladen handy tablet lädt auf und wir brauchen
6 watt excellent tablet lädt das ist sag mal so das ist so ungefähr man kann das noch
kalibrieren über das motor man kann das noch kalibrieren wenn man irgendwas hat was wirklich
gut misst man kann das noch kalibrieren das ist so ja also ja also man erkennt man erkennt
schon ob gerät an oder aus ist oder viel oder wenig verbraucht aber ich habe es ja ausprobiert
ich habe das mit so einem evl evl master dings ausprobiert die sind ja ganz ok mit
so einem ding master die lv lv lv ich habe das mit so einem ding hier ausprobiert und
das hier hat ein bisschen mehr gemessen als das zu 0,5 watt mehr aber also das hier bis
zu 0,5 aber das ist ok weil das ist man kann das noch kalibrieren man kann das noch kalibrieren
ja aber leute poggers in den chat hier es hat funktioniert es hat funktioniert das ist
wirklich massive ja ja evil chicken jetzt geht über nfc wobei das noch nicht alles
so ist wie ich es auf twitter geschrieben habe zum beispiel das dimmen spack noch ein
bisschen also aktuell macht er einfach aus dass 256 244 wird wahrscheinlich nicht stimmen
ja ja übrigens ist das sehr nice man kann man kann da jetzt also wie gesagt man sieht
hier dass das welche welche steckdose ist und an die hier die hier also die hier ist an
und max willst du eine richtige poggers home automation idee ja schieß los so die hier
ist an und das lädt gerade das tablet und das coole ist man sieht jetzt dass es funktioniert
mit 6 watt ich mache mal das andere aus aber was habe ich jetzt für einen ausgemacht
aus der falsche das zählt beides zusammen also das ist nicht verbraucht pro für eins
sondern quasi zusammen manchmal spackt es ein bisschen ach nee das ist die untere das
ist die untere das ist doch die obere gewinne ich habe ich habe doch das falsche ausgeschaltet
jetzt jetzt haben wir 6 watt genau mach laut selbst ja wie kommst du auf denn diese idee
die idee hatte ich auch schon mit den laut selbst die idee mit laut selbst hatte ich auch
schon aber das war noch nicht so gereift ich mache jetzt ich ich bin ich habe vor so eine
matte drunter zu machen unter unter das und die matratze so exzellent so also funktioniert
alles gut alles nice ja und das gute ist das kann man jetzt einbinden über das motor in
seinen in seinen home assistant was sind laut selbst eine waage waage eine waage und es kann
man sein home assistant einbinden und dann kann man auslesen wie gesagt was das aktuell
verbraucht und man sieht auch was das total verbraucht hat gestern verbraucht haben heute
verbrauchten also in kilowatt schon und die haben es übrigens richtig geschrieben ich
sehe total viele leute die schreiben kw durch ha aber es ist kw mal hat was eine menge ist
das wirklich ganz ganz nützlich esp home größer tas motor nee kannst du pauschal überhaupt
nicht sagen weil es komplett unterschiedliche anwendungszwecke hat das motor ist out of
the box wenn es kann ist super wenn es wenn du selbst logik machen willst ist esp home
besser wobei ich weg bin mittlerweile von esp home weil wenn ich wirklich custom logik
braucht programmiert die firma selbst ja also es kommt ungefähr hin es kommt ungefähr
hin es ist dann es ist nicht wirklich richtig richtig exakt aber zum beispiel unten funktioniert
es gut unten check ich damit ob der staubsauger akku aufgeladen ist sprich wenn es unter vier
watt ist dann weiß ich der ist voll und man kann es übrigens auch kalibrieren also das
hier das man kann tas motor kalibrieren also dieses wahrscheinlich einfach einfach auch
noch den bock schlecht eingestellt das ist mir sicherlich auch viel genauer aber das
mache ich jetzt nicht mehr wo hast du die kugel steckungsleistung bestellt bei amazon allerdings
die neuen sind mediatek und gehen nicht mehr soll heute bevor ich jetzt den stream beende
wie fandet ihr die sache mit der kamera das weiß man heute was ganz was anderes komplett
experimentier stell stream aber war schon irgendwie poggers oder war schon irgendwie
war schon irgendwie echt poggers das war aber aber wisst ihr was ich soll ich euch mal was
sagen ich bin jetzt wie lang wie lang bin ich
on drei stunden 20 ich komme mir vor als habe ich acht stunden gestreamt das ist echt
anstrengend das ist echt anstrengend also das machen wir nicht jedes mal
was für eine kamera das ist mein iphone iphone kamera
hast du meine lexta skills programmiert nein habe ich nicht noch nie ich mache mal kurz
hier wieder aus ich mache mal kurz wieder aus übrigens das licht hat sich nicht geändert
das ist nur die kamera die weiß abgleich anders macht so achso das natürlich hat sich
das geändert ich bin ja auch doof ich habe die beleuchtung ausgemacht ich kann so exzellent
so jetzt muss man gucken wie man das hier rauskriegt er das kannst du nicht das kann
also da muss ich auf jeden fall eine runde heißkleber rein machen und das zu pappen
also sollte ich das wirklich noch benutzen wollen da muss ich eine runde heißkleber
machen und zu pappen weil das geht hier fast raus das sagt das kann man den kann man keinem
zumuten gut sehr schön oh vielleicht soll ich das mal kurz mit
da reindrehen hier dann ist das bestimmt auch fest wenn ich das wieder reindrehe poggers
guckt mal aha ok jetzt kann ich das auch verwenden jetzt kann man das echt verwenden das ist
jetzt wirklich bombenfest wie wisst ihr was deswegen war das auch so krass fest am anfang
ich muss die schrauben quasi halb raus brechen dass das funktioniert warum ist denn das jetzt
wieder ausgegangen ach ich bin auf ausschalten gekommen quantum brain ja so ich gucke jetzt
noch mal schnell den chat keck weh macht er ich hätte gerne etwas damit automatisch
ein twitch channel oder video starten per befehl wo wo denn überhaupt wo auf was was für
endgeräte wo was wie viel zeit hast du zum zumachen gebraucht ja hätte ich es richtig
rum gemacht zwei minuten aber ich habe es erst falsch rum gemacht wenn ich es noch
mal mache bin ich in einer halben stunde durch wahrscheinlich ja ja ja und das gehäuse
sieht nicht so kaputt aus ich meine mal ernsthaft guck dich das mal an ich hab das licht schon
aus also die seite geht aber das hier ist halt echt rib aber jetzt mal ernsthaft leute
ja hättet ihr echt gedacht nachdem ich das angelötet hab dass das einfach so flasht
also es war schon echt sehr porz champ also ich hab wirklich l so da gesessen und gedacht
das flasht im leben nicht aber dann hat es trotzdem geflasht aber wie gesagt die sache
habe ich schon paar mal gemacht aber halt nicht mit dieser steckdose und schon gar nicht
so hier im stream und rumgefuddelt
den ton machen ja ich archiviere einfach den stream
würdest du den umstieg von einer auf was achso gtx auf rtx warum soll ich scroll jetzt mal
kurz durch ob ich irgendwas auch hier aber gesehen habe die steckdose leiste das hier
war irgendeine gosund sp 2 1 1 ok wunderbar leute ich gehe jetzt auf war schön dass so
viele am start waren war ein bisschen was anderes experimentier stream ja ich benutze home assistant
wir sehen uns leute die andere musik blick nicht mehr durch ok jetzt aber macht's gut
zu
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.